HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY. IS OUR HEARING
RELATED TO HIGHER EDUCATION
ISSUES FOR THAT STUDENT
COMMISSION FINANCIAL AID. AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY WILL BE PRIMARILY
FOCUSING TODAY'S HEARING ON
PROPOSALS. THAT ARE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED JANUARY
TENTH- BUDGET- THAT THE MAJOR-
ITEMS TODAY HER DEPARTMENT TODAY
THAT'S DIMINISH LIBRARY BUT IS
RELATED TO OUR STUDIO COMMISSION
ARE. MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
FINANCIAL AID- SYSTEM- THIS IS
THAT A TOP PRIORITY OF THE
ASSEMBLY IN THIS COMMITTEE. TO
FOCUS ON EXPANDING COLLEGE
ACCESS WE ALL KNOW THAT- YEAH
THE TICKET TO THE MIDDLE CLASS
IS A COLLEGE EDUCATION AND OUR
EMPLOYERS NEED MORE COLLEGE
GRADUATES SO. THOSE TWO THINGS
COMBINEDYOU KNOW MAKE IT
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON WE ALSO THAT FINANCIAL
AID IN THE COST OF COLLEGE
EARNED MAJOR IMPEDIMENT- LAST
YEAR WE TOOK A MAJOR MAJOR STEP
WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF. OUR- OUR
HIGHER. EDUCATION SURE OVER HERE
. THE LEGISLATION. AND COMPARE
BUDGET REQUEST TO REFORM
FINANCIAL AID TO FIX FINANCIAL
AID TO COVER. THE THE NON
TUITION COSTS. AND WELL THE BILL
WAS IT. WAS IT SUCCESS ONE
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR THE
CONTENTS OF THE BILL WERE IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND I LIKE TO
REALLY FOCUS THAT IT WAS A GLASS
HALF FULL WE GOT- OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW FINANCIAL AID-
EXPANDING- FOR FINANCIAL AID
COLLEGE ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA THE
BIGGEST PIECE OF THAT. WAS
HAVING A HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENTITLEMENT
AWARDS FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS SO
THEY CAN COVER THE NON TUITION
COSTS LIKE BOOKS HOUSING AND SO
FORTH- WE UPDATE THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. TO PROVIDE
MORE AID TO STUDENTS AND START
ADDRESSING THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE AND THAT- WILL FOCUS
ON. EXPANDING BOTH FOR THE UC
AND CSU- AND THEN REALLY THE
LONG TERM GOAL IS HOW WE GET TO
DEBT FREE COLLEGE TO HAVE
STUDENTS GRADUATE. WITHOUT DEBT-
WHEN THEY GET THEIR COLLEGE
DEGREE. THAT WE ALSO PURSUED-
NOTEWORTHY- LEGISLATION THE
BUDGET ACTION LAST YEAR THAT
THAT OUR MAJORITY LEADER
CHAMPION. TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS FILL OUT
THE FAFSA FORM OR THE DREAM ACT-
AND CREATE. A SUCCESS TO MAKE
SURE WE GET MORE FINANCIAL AID-
IN THE HANDS OF STUDENTS WHO
NEED IT- BUT WE'RE NOT THAT THE
FINANCIALLY REFORM. OUR PETS
ACTUALLY HALFWAY THERE AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO FINISH THE JOB-
THIS YEAR SO THIS IS ONE OF THE-
MAJOR ISSUES ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT- NOT. TOO MUCH YET FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT YOU
KNOW THE ASSEMBLY WILL CERTAINLY
MAKE IT A PRIORITY IN OUR
BUDGET- WITH THAT LET'S- THE-
TODAY'S HEARING. WITH CALL THE
ROLL. MCCARTY LATE. MEDINA I
DON'T HEAR REYES YEAH. CORMAN'S
ESTABLISH OKAY. THE LEAD AGAIN
THE HEARING WITH- THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. IN ISSUE
NUMBER ONE IS- CAL GRANT
EXPANSION REFORM. WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELADIO IN
THE CITY COMMISSION. BERMAN TO
FINANCE WITH US. VIRTUALISED YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS.
CHECK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WELCOME PROGRAM THE
STATE MARKETS FINANCIAL AID. IS
EXPECTED TO SERVE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS.
TWO TWENTY THREE. BUDGET US THAT
AT ALL BUT TO OF THREE POINT
EIGHT. OF WHICH THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION SUPPORTERS THE COCHRAN
PROGRAM AND THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION AFTER THE STATE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO MAKE
COLLEGE ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
JUST LAST YEAR WE HAVE THE
BIGGEST EXPANSION OF THE COCHRAN
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM SINCE THE
PROGRAM'S INCEPTION. CONSULTING
MORE THAN A SEVENTY. STUDENTS
NEWLY ELIGIBLE THE TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ENTITLEMENT EXPANSION IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
STUDENTS WHO DEMONSTRATE
FINANCIAL NEED BUT DO NOT MEET
ALL THE CRITERIA OR THE KIND OF
IN A WORST. THANK ALL OF FIVE
FOR ONE OF THE THIRTEEN THOUSAND
PROPOSED COMPETITIVE CONFERENCE
AWARDS. I THANK YOU AND I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU L. A. F. THROUGHOUT
THE L. A. OVER THIS. YES I'M
SORRY GUYS I STILL NEED GOOD
MORNING IN NUMBERS BE THINKING
THAT LED ANALYST'S OFFICE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BY ALIGNS CAL CAN'T
WITH THE MOVE RECENT IF THAT
MAKE A PAYMENT BY THE STEVEN
COMMISSION. IT ACTED TO INCREASE
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. AND THE MOST NOTABLE GOT
THAT INCREASE PHYSICAL TO. THAT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF INTO
PRO AS WE CAN DISCUSS. EVEN IS
EXPECTED UPDATE IT CONTENTS
AFTER THAT THE MAYOR ENTER. WITH
RECENT AVAILABLE DATA. AND
FAMILY RECOMMEND WHERE UNTIL MAY
TO FIND ANY BUDGET DECISIONS.
THANK HAVE A TAKEN. OKAY THANK
YOU THAT'S STATE COMMISSION.
GOOD CHAIR MCCARTY MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE I'M SICK
PRIMARY DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AND EXTERNAL RELATIONS WITH THIS
YOU NEED COMMISSION IT'S GREAT
TO BE WITH YOU THIS MORNING-
I'VE TO BEGIN MY REMARKS BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE TREMENDOUS
DEBT THAT WE MADE LAST YEAR TO
THE POINT THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST RAISED THE LARGEST
EXPANSION OF THE PELL GRANT
ACCESS SINCE THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM WAS CREATED- AND I HAVE
TO EXTEND OUR GRATITUDE ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION YOU. YES SENATE
GOVERNOR AND PARTICULAR OUR
LEGISLATIVE. YEAH YOU WILL SURE
MCCARTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AND HER COLLEAGUE SENATOR LEYVA
. AND WELL WE'VE MADE THAT
TREMENDOUS FIRST THAT WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE STILL CRITICAL
GAPS IN OUR CAL GRANT SYSTEM-
AND HOW IT SERVING TODAY'S
STUDENT. YOUR GENDER MATERIAL
STEVEN BUT GREAT JOB AT SPEAKING
ABOUT THE REMAINING GAPS IN
ACCESS TO THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS DEMONSTRATING THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS CURRENT
APPROACH TO STATE FINANCIAL AID.
WE KNOW THAT OFTEN OUR LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS ALSO LACKED THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT TO ADDRESS
THEIR EXPENSES OUTSIDE OF
TUITION LIKE HOUSING FOOD
TECHNOLOGY TRANSPORTATION BOOKS
AND OTHER SUPPLIES. THIS IS YOUR
AID COMMISSION BELIEVE THE STEP
. IT THE FIRST ISSUE TOO MUCH.
IS IN ACT TO THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS FOR ALL OF OUR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS PURSUING HIGHER
EDUCATION BY REMOVING THOSE
REMAINING BARRIERS TO STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM. AND IT'S GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD ON THE
MOMENTUM FROM LAST YEAR'S
MASSIVE EXPANSION OF ACCESS TO
CONGREGATE AT WHICH ALL SHARES
MORE DATA ON IN JUST A MOMENT.
WHAT WE ARE ABLE TO REMOVE SOME
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
GROUP THAT BUDGET ACT CHANGE
LAST YEAR. THERE ARE STILL OTHER
BARRIERS BASED ON. WHEN A
STUDENT ENTERS A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION AS A FRESHMAN. OR
HOW THEY TRANSFER TO ANOTHER
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY. REQUIREMENTS
TO PROVIDE A TRANSCRIPT OR GPA
DATA WILL ALSO KEEP OUT MANY OF
OUR ADULT LEARNERS FROM
ACCESSING CALTRAIN EIGHT WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE QUALIFY BASED ON
THEIR INCOME STATUS. COMMENTS
ARE RATIONING MECHANISM FOR
STATE FINANCIAL AID THAT TO
SUPPORT FOR DISPROPORTIONATELY
EXCLUDE OUR ADULT AND RETURNING
LEARNERS DESPITE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PROBABLY SERVING THE
TOP 1100% OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. HOW GRANT ALSO REALLY RIGHT A
MAJOR RATHER THAN A STRAIGHT
PATHWAY TO AFFORDABILITY. AS
YOUR GENDER WOULD KNOW WE HAVE
OVER A DIFFERENT CAL GRANT TODAY
- BOOK EVEN. OTHER NEW SPECIAL
PROGRAM THAT AN ESTABLISHED TO
HELP PROMOTE PATHWAYS TO PROJECT
. THIS MAY UNDERSTANDING AND
THAT THE SYSTEM CHALLENGING FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE THAT MIGHT BE THE
FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE. THIS TECHNIQUE
COMMISSION HAS PROPOSED REMOVING
THESE BARRIERS AND STREAMLINING
THE PROGRAMS BY ESTABLISHING A
CAL GRANT YOU FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND A TOP
REPORTER FOR STUDENTS AT PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE. UNIVERSITIES WHILE
THERE ARE STILL WE'RE STILL
REFINING OR COST ESTIMATES BASED
ON THE CHANGES TO FINANCIAL AID
LAST YEAR AND DISCUSSION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ABOUT
REASONABLE ASSUMPTIONS TO MAKE
AROUND- STUDENT ENROLLMENT AND
CATHOLIC GROWTH AS WE WOULD CALL
HIM THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. WE
DO HAVE SOME INITIAL DATA ABOUT
HOW MANY MORE STUDENTS WE COULD
SERVE IF WE WERE TO MAKE THESE
CHANGES. AND JUST TO THINK WHAT
YOU'RE A FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS THE FIRST ONE WE
MOVED NEW. PROPOSED CAL
GRANT U. N. FORCES DOWN THERE
WOULD BE A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS FOR FINANCIAL AID. AND
STUDENT YOU BRING ANOTHER
PROGRAM ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
THOSE FOR LATINO. AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS. AND AS I
NOTED WERE STILL REQUIRED THAT'S
BECAUSE US TO. THE BALLPARK
RANGE THAT COULD GIVE WITH.
SOMEWHERE BUT TO HONOR AND
FIFTY. TO THREE HUNDRED MILLION
IN NYC ONGOING FUN. TO ESTABLISH
CALGARY YOU AND THE CALIFORNIA
FOR- USING THE SAME METHODOLOGY
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
UTILIZE FOR THE PELL GRANT
PROGRAM SO THAT ANY STUDENT
THAT'S ELIGIBLE FOR A PELL GRANT
IS ALSO ELIGIBLE. FOR CAL GRANT
YOU WERE CALTRANS FOR. AND I'M
I'M HAPPY NOT A SHIRT SOME OF
THE INITIAL DATA ABOUT LAST
YEAR'S EXPANSION OF A FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. GO
AHEAD TAKE. YES DEMOCRATIC. YES
COULD YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND DO
THAT RIGHT NOW. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU. SO IT LAST YEAR'S EXPANSION
OF EIGHT FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS I'M PLEASED TO SHARE
THAT- WE WERE ABLE TO TURN
AROUND AFTER THE SIGNING OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION BUDGET TRAILER
BILL IN LATE JULY WE WERE ABLE
TO THAT IN NOVEMBER PROCESSES
OUR FIRST ROUND OF NEW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT
WARDS THIS YIELDED A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND OFFERED
AWARDS TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. JUST IN NOVEMBER IN
JANUARY BE PROCESS ANOTHER BATCH
OF FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS AS
MORE DATA IS SUBMITTED TO THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION IN
COMPLETING A STUDENT'S
APPLICATION FOR AID THAT YIELDED
ANOTHER FORTY THOUSAND OFFERS-
OF AWARDS TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
THE DIRECT FROM YOU MAKE TO PASS
YEARS BEFORE WE HAD THIS NEW.
ACCESS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WOULD BE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS OFFERED AN
AWARD TO A COMPETITIVE CAL RANT
PROGRAMS. THAT IT OFFERED ABOUT
FORTY ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS AT
THE COLLEGES WITH A CALTRANS
WORKER. THIS REPRESENTS A NET
INCREASE OF ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
HOW GREAT STUDENTS AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I MISS IT
BECAUSE OF THE WORK OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE YOUR PARTNERS IN
THE SENATE AND GOVERNOR NEW SOME
SIGNING LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. SO
AGAIN HAVE TO EXPRESS HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE. AND OKAY WHAT
WE ARE STILL PROCESSING-
INCOMING INFORMATION FROM THE
COLLEGES THAT CONFIRMS THAT THE
STUDENTS BEEN PAID OUT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ALL OF THE STUDENTS
ACTUALLY GET PAID WE KNOW THIS
THE THOUSANDS MORE STUDENTS THAN
WE'VE SERVED IN THE PAST. OF THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS SUCH NOTED.
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
CONFIRMED AS AN WORLD BY OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THEIR
CAMPUS I'M. WHICH THIRD WORLD-
UPDATES FROM OUR CAMP IS SO FAR
ABOUT HOW MANY THESE PEOPLE THEY
HAVE.OUT FOR THAT CAMPUS LET.
SUGGEST THAT FIFTY TWO. OF THE
STATE. HAVE ALREADY BEEN PAID
THEIR WORK. THAT'S ABOUT THIRTY
SAID PERCENT OF THE TOTAL
CONFIRMED ANY ROLE STUDENTS. I
SHOULD TRANSPORT FROM YEAR- ARE
PRETTY- INDICATED. ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE THOUSAND.
STUDENTS WOULD RECEIVE AN AWARD
THIS YEAR THREE THE ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM. AT OUR QUESTIONS AND
HAPPY TO SHARE MORE ABOUT SOME
FACTORS THAT MIGHT BE AT PLAY.
IN WOULD NOT SEEN ALL OF THOSE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS BE
PAPERWORK THAT- CORPORATE READY
THANK ALL ALSO. MY COMMENT THERE
. OKAY THANK YOU I'LL HAVE SOME
TIME. QUESTIONS TO FOLLOW
QUESTION AB BUT THE FIRST OF GO
BACK TO THE OF FINANCE- THAT AS
YOU NOTED- GABRIELA HE ARE YOU
THERE. HI YES I'M HERE OKAY YES
A TO SAY WORDS WE CAN QUIT KEEP
TALKING SO WE CAN SEE. THE
MORNING. THERE YOU ARE OKAY YES
IT WOULD ARE HAVING WE DO A-
YOUR COMMENTS AND AS NOTED
EARLIER- LAST YEAR WAS- ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE ELEMENTS OF OUR
ONCE IN A. GENERATION BUDGET
WAS. HAVING THE LARGEST INCREASE
IN FINANCIAL AID. IN DECADES
SINCE THIS TIME IT WAS CREATED
IN TWO THOUSAND- AND WE NOTED
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE
OVER COMPANION BILL AND I KNOW.
MR MEDINA AND I SPOKE TO THE
GOVERNOR AND WE CAN MAKE TO THE
MUTUAL CONCLUSION THAT. WE WERE
SUPER EXCITED WAS THERE LAST
YEAR THE GLASSES MORE THAN HALF
FULL BUT THE GOVERNOR SAID
SPECIFICALLY I'M GOING TO VETO
THIS BILL. IN THIS ISSUE IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IT SHOULD BE
DISCUSSED. IN THE- THE PROCESS
AND SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
ON JANUARY TEN. YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE A
BUDGET. AND THERE WAS NOTHING
NEW THERE WAS SOME MONEY TO
IMPLEMENT. LAST YEAR'S-
ARRANGEMENTS SO WHY DO WE SEE
ANY- WHAT WHAT WHY WHAT WHY WHY
WHY WHY DO WE HAVE LACKING A NEW
PROPOSAL FROM YOU ALL. AS FAR AS
FURTHERING- FINANCIAL EXPANSION
TO OUR CALVET PROGRAM. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION CHAIR OF FROM
THE PROMISED PERSPECTIVE THE
RECENT EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM-
REALLY HIGHLIGHTS OF BIGGEST
INVESTMENT SINCE THE PROGRAM'S
INCEPTION- SO WE WHAT WE WILL
LIKE TO ANALYZE. THE IMPACT OF
THOSE INVESTMENTS BEFORE MAKING
ADDITIONAL CHANGES. I WOULD ALSO
JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT AN
EXPANSION OF AN ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE COCKER
PROGRAM CAN BE CONSIDERED A
COSTLY. THERE'S ALSO A FAIR
AMOUNT OF UNCERTAINTY PEOPLE ARE
BECAUSE OF THE PROGRAM IS AN
ENTITLEMENT SO EVEN IF THERE'S A
PROJECTED COSTS AND SYSTEM LEVEL
SECONDS THE TYPICAL TATE
SIGNIFICANTLY. LESS CABLES
INCREASES OR DECREASES OVER
TIME. AND FROM THE PROGRAM FROM
THE PROPONENTS RESPECT EXPANDING
AND ENTITLEMENT. PROGRAM IS
ALWAYS SOMEWHAT RISKY AND A
CONCERN US IT OF WHAT IF YOU
LIMITS THAT BUT IT AFFECTS. AS
WELL AS TO SEND SOMETHING
LIABILITY THE IN GO INTO. OKAY
SO YOU'RE THINKING OF THE SAN.
WE HEAR YOU THIS IS A OF THE AT
THE SAME. AND THIS SEPT CAN WE
GO BACK TO- PER FOR THE HE A
PRIME PERSON BERMAN BERMAN. FROM
THE FRONT THE SENATE COMMISSION
AND YOU OF COURSE WE THE PARTNER
LAST YEAR AND IT'S- ARLA. CAN
CAN YOU OUTLINE A WHAT PIECES
THAT WE DID NOT COMPLETE FROM
YEAR'S REFORM FOR. AND THEN WHAT
THE ESTIMATED COST FOR
COMPLETING THOSE. YES CHAIR
MCCARTY HAPPY TO DO SO- THE
REMAINING GAPS IN ELIGIBILITY
AND ESSENTIALLY BARRIERS THAT
PREVENT STUDENTS FROM ACCESSING
A CAL GRANT THAT ARE
DISCONNECTED FROM THEIR
FINANCIAL STATUS THERE ARE A FEW
WOULD BE THAT WE STILL NEED TO
TAKE ON. WE STILL HAVE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ARE ENTERING
FRESHMEN STUDENTS AT FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES AND PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS BASED ON WHEN THEY
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
IN THE CASE OF STUDENTS
TRANSFERRING TO THOSE
UNIVERSITIES FROM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GUARANTEED CALTRAIN ACCESS EVEN
IF THEY'RE FINANCIALLY ELIGIBLE
IF THEY HAVE NOT FIRST RECEIVED
A CAL GRANT BEFORE GOING TO A
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY THEY'LL NEED
TO BE- UNDER AGE TWENTY EIGHT TO
GET THAT ENTITLEMENT. AND THEY
STILL ALSO NEED TO BE UNDER AGE
TWENTY EIGHT IN ORDER TO HAVE
GUARANTEED- ELIGIBILITY FOR
CALIBRATED FINANCIALLY ELIGIBLE
ACADEMICALLY ELIGIBLE IF THEY'RE
TRANSFERRED TO A PRIVATE
UNIVERSITY SO WE TOOK AWAY MUCH
OF THE AGE CAP AS WE CALL IT ON
CAL GRANT BUT WE DIDN'T FULLY
ELIMINATE THAT. IN ORDER TO BE
FULLY ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT
THAT IS YOU CAN APPLY FOR AN
ENTITLEMENT- WITHIN ONE YEAR
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION WE
ALSO HAVE THAT GPA AND
TRANSCRIPT REQUIREMENT THAT I
MENTIONED FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. WHICH WE KNOW
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS THOSE
RETURNING ADULT LEARNERS WHO
WERE WORKING SO HARD TO TRY. TO
SERVE AND FIND NEW WAYS TO SERVE
. BILL THIS WOULD BE KEY ELLAGIC
. GAPS MISSILE WE MADE FINANCIAL
MORE AND- LAST YEAR IT'S BUT A
MORE CHEN PER IT BECAME MORE
CALM. BECAUSE WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT SET OF REQUIREMENTS
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
MEETING FOR THE DEEP FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS- THAT'S WHERE WE
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
TRY TO STREAMLINE THESE
PROGRAMS. REDUCE FROM EIGHT
PROGRAMS TO AND THEN ALSO A LOT
OF THOSE PROGRAMS WITH THE NEW
FEDERAL ELIGIBILITY SYSTEM. IT'S
GOING TO COME AND IN THE
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION CYCLE
THAT BEGINS IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. STILL CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO ROLL OUT ITS- MORE
SIMPLIFIED STREAMLINED APPROACH
TO FINANCIAL AID. PRINT
CURRENTLY WITH THE NEW
SIMPLIFIED FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM THAT WILL START IN THAT
APPLICATIONS LIKE ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THIS IS REALLY THE
HERE WE NEED TO TAKE THOSE STEPS
MAKE THOSE POLICY CHANGES SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT READY TO
GO IN A PROCESS STUDENTS. I
THINK FIRST OF. OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY. AND CHECK THE SECOND
PARTY DO YOU DO YOU HAVE A
BALLPARK ON. THE- ESTIMATE FOR.
ACHIEVING THOSE. THOSE THAT
OUTSTANDING GOALS. YES SORRY MR
ONE SHARE SO- A NOTE PREVIOUS WE
IN CAN YOU. WITH THE PART OF
FINDING BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE ANY COST ESTIMATES WE
PRODUCE ISRAELI AIR TIGHT AND
REFLECT ANY. METHODOLOGICAL
ASSUMPTIONS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WOULD ADVISE US
PARTICULARLY AROUND- PROJECTIONS
FOR STUDENT INVOLVEMENT AND ITS
EFFECT ON CASELOAD. HOW MANY CAL
GRANT STUDENTS ARE APPLYING TO
ELIGIBLE IN THOSE YEARS THAT WE
KNOW DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CONCERNED WITH. I CAN GIVE YOU A
BALLPARK THIS IS NOT A FINAL
ESTIMATE AS WE ARE WAITING FOR A
RESPONSE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ABOUT. WHAT THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS SHOULD BE BUT THE
BALLPARK WOULD BE ON THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS SIDE. PROBABLY
200-523-0050 MILLION IN NEW
ONGOING FUNDING. AND THE OTHER
PIECE I WOULD NOTICE AS YOU
EXPAND ACCESS TO THE CALIFORNIA
. THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND ELIGIBLE
THAT IS ONE OF THE KEY POP WITH
OUT OF THE CALVERT OFTEN BASED
ON DOES NOT BARRIERS THAT MEANS
THAT IF YOU WANT TO MAINTAIN THE
SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR ACCESS THE
WORD THAT WE PROVIDE TO STUDENTS
PARENTS CURRENTLY THERE WOULD
ALSO BE A NEED FOR AN
APPROPRIATION TO KEEP THAT
PROGRAM HOLE SO THAT AS WE SERVE
MORE STUDENTS PARENTS WE CANNOT
KEEP THAT SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR
IMPORTANT PLACE AND THAT NUMBER
I BELIEVE IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO
BE BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TO ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ON GOING TO KEEP THIS
DEPARTMENT PURPLE. OKAY THANK
YOU. TO OPT OUT. CERTAINLY COME
BACK. THIS ISSUE- LATER IN THE
YEAR. MR MEDINA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- SO I ATE HERE IN
THE DISCUSSION I UNDERSTAND THAT
NOT ONLY IT'S NOT ONLY A BUDGET
ISSUE MY CORRECT IN THAT- IN
ORDER TO REMOVE SOME OF THE
BARRIERS THAT YOU ADDRESS THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE GPA AND
TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL. WE
WOULD NEED LEGISLATION IS ACT.
IN ORDER IN ORDER TO REMOVE THE
BARRIERS SO IT CANNOT ALL BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN THE BUDGET.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA I THINK-
WE HAVE THIS CHALLENGE WITH CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS CHANGES WHERE WE
KNOW IT IS A SIGNIFICANT POLICY
CHANGE BUT ALSO ONE THAT TAKES
FUNDING- WE WERE VERY PLEASED OF
COURSE THANKS TO YOUR LEADERSHIP
TO FEET. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
LAST YEAR CLEAR THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WITH UNANIMOUS APPROVAL-
THAT BEING SAID WE THINK THAT
THE WAY WE CAN UNDERTAKE THESE
CHANGES IN THIS YEAR IS TO TAKE
THE APPROACH WE DID WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM. LAST YEAR AND FUND
THOSE CHANGES AND THEN UTILIZE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO MAKE A
POLICY CHANGES WE OF COURSE HAVE
OUR OUR LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE AS
WELL UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. TODAY WE CAN GO
THROUGH THE POLICY PROCESS WITH
AFTER FULL DISK. ABOUT WHAT THE
- ARE FOR STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA YEAH AND I AGREE VERY
MUCH THAT THE- SIMPLIFYING THE
PROCESSES IS ALSO. VERY
IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS IN ORDER
TO BETTER. NAVIGATE AND APPLY-
UNDER ON THE MATTER OF THE
PROGRAM WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS DOING- AND THAT'S
ANOTHER GOAL I BELIEVE OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE THIS
YEAR IS TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS- REFLECTS THE
CHANGES IN THE FEDERAL FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM WHAT WHAT WOULD WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF- IF WE DIDN'T DO
THAT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF. WE
DIDN'T MAKE THE APPROPRIATE
CHANGES TO OUR STATE FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MAKES DIFFERENT
CHANGES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
I THINK THE KEY ISSUE THERE IS
REALLY A MISSED OPPORTUNITY THAT
SHOULD WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
NEW FEDERAL SYSTEM THAT WILL
HAVE A STREAMLINED AND
SIMPLIFIED APPS THAT- TOWARD THE
GOAL OF THEN PROVIDING A LOOK UP
TABLE WE'RE A FAMILY COULD
SIMPLY LOOK UP BASED ON THEIR
HOUSEHOLD STATUS. AND THEIR
HOUSEHOLD SIZE BUT THE INCOME
CEILING IS TO GET SOME KIND OF
HELP GRANT AWARD. WE WILL HAVE A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT SYSTEM FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES TO UTILIZE
TO UNDERSTAND IF THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE FINANCIAL
AID- YOU'RE PROPOSING FROM THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND WITH
YOUR SUPPORT. IS TO MOVE TOWARD
A SYSTEM WHERE WE CAN USE THAT
SAME LOOK UP TABLE IF IT'S
CALLED SO THAT IS STUDENT AND-
MEMBER FAMILY CAN LOOK AT THAT
TABLE FIND THAT INCOME CEILING
AND UNDERSTAND THEIR ELIGIBLE
FOR BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE.
FINANCIAL AID THROUGH THE PELL
GRANT AND THROUGH THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS- IF WE WERE TO NOT MAKE
THOSE CHANGES THIS YEAR- BUT WE
WERE TO DO SO AT A LATER YEAR WE
WOULD HAVE A FEW CONSECUTIVE
YEARS OF MAJOR CHANGES IN THE
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM THAT. MIGHT
BE BETTER TAKEN COMPREHENSIVELY
AND MOVING FORWARD TOGETHER
RATHER THAN PUTTING FORWARD A
NEW FEDERAL SYSTEM IN YOUR ONE
AND YOUR STATE SYSTEM IN YOUR TO
WORK. PRETTY. IT ABOUT HOW WE
COMMUNICATE TO STUDENTS FAMILIES
ELEGY. FOR SO THE- THEREFORE AT
WOULD I TAKE THERE IS. AS OF
VERGE. TO THIS DONE THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR THERE IS YES.
THANK YOU MISTER DONNA. YES SIR
MY QUESTION IS OF BASIC- IN FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU
MAY NOT KNOW THE ANSWER RIGHT
NOW YOU MAY DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH
EACH SEGMENT COLLECTS EACH YEAR
IN TUITION MEANING- CSU AND UC
OLIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGES OUT OF
IT BECAUSE THEIR TUITIONS FREE
BUT DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH THEY
COLLECTED IN STUDENT FEES OR
WHAT WE'LL CALL TUITION. FOR OUR
PURPOSES TODAY. IN TOTAL. MR
DOWNS JAX WEALTH OVER FINANCE- I
DO KNOW THAT INFORMATION BUT I
DON'T HAVE IT HANDY I CAN'T GIVE
YOU THAT I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOUR STEPHENS IN THE LONG.
THANK YOU YEAH I WOULD. YOU TO
HAVE A BUT I'M JUST LOOKING AT
THIS EXERCISE MORTGAGE IN HERE.
AND I'LL AT A YOUNG AGE NOT PEE
IN THE WIND. AND I WONDER IF
WE'RE DOING THAT WHY DON'T WE
JUST MAKE COLLEGE FREE. I MEAN
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF LOGISTICS
INFRASTRUCTURE. STAFF ASSOCIATED
WITH ALL THESE BILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAMS. TO BUY DOWN THE
TUITION AND TO ME IT'S A NO
BRAINER. TO JUST TAKE SOME OF
THIS MONEY. AND MAKE THE TUITION
NONEXISTENT I KNOW LEGALLY I
THINK WE DON'T CHARGE THEM
TUITION WE CHARGING FEES BECAUSE
OF THAT THE MASTER PLAN WHICH I
BELIEVE CALLED FOR THESE
SEGMENTS TO BE FREE NOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BY AND LARGE
FOR A HAVE A DAUGHTER THAT GOES
THEIR FIRST YEAR RIGHT FREE
COLLEGE PROMISE OF WHICH WE DID
MR MCCARTY LED THE EFFORT ON
THAT. BUT TO ME IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE WE HAD TO REBOOT THIS WHOLE
EFFORT AND RETHINK WHAT WE'RE
DOING BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE GOOD PEOPLE WORKING HARD
TO SERVE THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS SITTING OFFICES RIGHT
NOW PROBABLY DEALING WITH
PAPERWORK CENTER TRYING TO GET
KIDS JUST SAY TO. SOURCES WOULD
BE BETTER AND JUST MAKING THIS
EFFORT FREE. THAT'S MY EDITORIAL
STRUCTURE. OKAY I. OTHER
QUESTIONS ON THAT I WILL NOTE-
MISTER DONALD THIS THAT YOUR
OVERARCHING THING IS 100% TRUE
IS THAT YOU TAKE SOMEBODY WITH A
PHD TO FIGURE OUT ALL THESE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE TRYING TO SIMPLIFY MAKE IT
EASIER THAT'S HALF WE DID LAST
YEAR. BUT YOU KNOW I THINK IT UC
AND CSU ON THE ROAD IN FRONT OF
US LIKE ROUGHLY TWO THIRDS OR
SO. DON'T PAY ANY FEES AT ALL
PEENE. TUITION SO IT'S REALLY
THE NON TUITION COSTS WHY
STUDENTS WE HEAR FROM OUR
STUDENTS LATER IN THE DAY THAT
PUTS THEM. IN AND FINANCIAL
PERIL IS A SO MUCH DAD IT'S ALL
THE OTHER COSTS OF- YEAH THAT'S
A WE'RE TRYING TO GET A WE HAVE
A BALANCING ACT SO. ALL WELL AND
GOOD FOR CHARITY I THINK
STUDENTS AREN'T AFRAID TO WORK I
HAVE A- STUDENT LIVING IN MY
HOUSE MY DAUGHTER THAT GOES TO
WORK I WORKED I DROVE A TOW
TRUCK FOUR DAYS A WEEK FIFTEEN
HOUR SHIFTS. BUILDS CHARACTER SO
AGAIN I THINK THE STARTING POINT
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE ON A B.
TUITION FREE YEAH. WELL THAT THE
WERE A LOT OF YOU HAVE TO GATHER
I DON'T KNOW BUT THERE ARE BILL
THAT MR MEDINA HIGHER OFFERING
WITH LEYVA. IT'S IT IF THE
FORMULA FOR DEBT FREE COLLEGE IS
STUDENTS AFTER THIS. YOU TAKE
YOUR FIND YOUR PARENTS FINANCIAL
SITUATION BASED UPON HOW MUCH
INCOME YOU HAVE TO PUT ON THE
TABLE FRANCE LATE. THE SUIT HAS
TO WORK FIFTEEN HOURS A WEEK. SO
THAT'S PART OF OUR OF OUR GOAL
OUR CONTACT IS THAT YES WE THINK
THAT THERE IS A- OPPORTUNITY AN
OBLIGATION FOR. STUDENTS AND
PARENTS TO PARTICIPATE SO. I
OCCURRED YOUR PER. WITH OUR BILL
I KNOW THERE'S A BUT IT CAN TO
HIRE BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT THESE
EXACT SAME ISSUES ON ON OUR END
AND AGAIN IT'S OKAY TO HELP THE
MIDDLE CLASS AS WELL. YEP IT IS
OKAY TO DO THAT WELL I DON'T
KNOW IT TOO I KNOW THAT YOU ARE
WE DON'T REALLY TALK ABOUT HERE
BUT THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP. CEMEX HIS IS COMING
UP. AND THAT WAS A BIG PIECE TO
MAKE SURELY HELP MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES NOT ONLY FOR TUITION
BUT PROVIDE SOME- NON TUITION
SUPPORT FOR. FOR AND MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES SO WITH THAT WILL
HOLD ISSUE ONE OPEN. IN PROCEEDS
ISSUE NUMBER TWO- THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP.
IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE BASICALLY
IT'S A IT'S A REBOOT FROM WHAT
WE- CREATED BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. TWENTY FIFTEEN TO HELP
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST OVER.
ELIGIBILITY ASSERT THAT. I
WEALTHY IN IN TODAY'S CALIFORNIA
WITH ALL THE OTHER COSTS SUCH AS
HOUSING SO. WE ARE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LEN. STUDENT COMMISSION
PLEASE PROCEED. THE MONEY CHAIR
COMMITTEE MAY. OF THE CALL.
BUDGET INCLUDES ONE THIRTY
MILLION ON. GENDER FUND. TO
SUPPORT THE REVISED MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM ENACTED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET AT.
WHICH TAKES EFFECT IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
EXPANDED THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. LIVE MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS NEARLY ELIGIBLE. THANK
YOU AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY L. A. L.
THANK YOU. EIGHTY SEVEN DESCRIBE
THE THICKNESS REVAMPS THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM THAT'S
PLAN. FOR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. JUST A MINUTE CRIED WE'RE
AMOUNTS WILL BE HELPED UNDER
THIS WEEKEND PROGRAM. THE THING
WHAT AMOUNTS SOLELY ON TUITION
TRY. BUT WHAT ABOUT WILL BECOME
BASED ON THE TOLL COST OF. TO
OPPOSE THAT INVOLVES A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT. YOU NEED WILL COME
WHAT REMAINING COSTA THE STUDENT
. AFTER FOR OTHER GETS SUCH
CALIFORNIA. CONTRA BECAUSE TIME
WORK COULD BE DEFENDED BY. MOST
OF COUNTRY SPECIFICALLY STUDENTS
HOUSEHOLD INCOME A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR OR MORE. YOU
NEED ME WILL DETERMINE WHAT.
ABOUT STUDENTS BECAUSE COME.
FIFTY THE ANNUAL FUNDING
INCLUDING THE FACT. AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED LEVEL SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO ON. IT MADE
IT THAT WOULD 20% OF EACH FROM
CALL. YOU'LL HEAR FROM AID
COMMISSION ABOUT PROGRESS THEY
MAY IN MY THIS FOR. I DID THE
FLY IN ADVANCE FOR YOU BY ISSUE
THE IS. IN YOUR AGENDA. IT NOT
THAT EACH STUDENTS AWAY AMOUNT
INVOLVE SIGNIFICANT. BETWEEN THE
STUDENT COMMISSION CAMPUS AID
OFFICE AS- A RESULT THERE'S AN-
ANY RIGHT NOW AS TO WHEN TO WORK
WILL BE FOR STUDENT. AND IN
PARTICULAR WHETHER WILL HAVE
THAT AND IN HAND THE MIDDLE
SCHOLARSHIP WHAT ABOUT THIS ONE
COMES TIME TO MAKE IN THE THAT.
FOR THE. TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY. THANK YOU THE HAPPY TO
TAKE A CLASS. FOR THE TEN YEAR
THANK YOU- THAT PART. OF POST A
COMMISSION. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
SO AS OUR OUR CALL AT LA NOTED
ALL PROVIDER YOU UP YOUR ON THE
YOU NEED COMMISSION ROGRESS IN
MOVING FORWARD AN EMPLOYEE THIS
NEW AND SICK REVISE THE PRODUCT
TO THE MIDDLE SCHOOL BROKE. DO
COMMISSION HAD TO CONVENE THE
GROUP WITH OUR PARTNER AT THE
SEE IN THE CSU. TO UNDERSTAND
HOW WE CAN WORK TO THE BIGGER OF
THE- WE'VE ALSO- BEEN WORK WITH
THE- ANALYST. YOU SEE AN CSU TO
HELP AND REFINE COST ESTIMATE
FOR FULL. OF THE PROBE. USING
STUDENT LEVEL- AT THIS CAN AN
ADDITIONAL DATA THE YOU SEE IN
FEES PROVIDE ABOUT THEIR- EIGHT.
AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA UPDATED
COSTA. THE THAT TOTAL FUNDING
FOR HIM TO. WOULD APPROXIMATELY
TWO PER SIX BILL DOLLARS
FUNDING. AND AT THIS UPCOMING
YEAR WE WILL SERVE CLEARANCE
DOLLARS STUDENTS. THIS PROGRAM.
INCLUDING THIS WE TRYING TO IN
BASED AND TO DEMONSTRATE HOW MAY
FUNDING AND THE AVERAGE OF WORK
WITH LIKE JUST YOU ACROSS A
RANGE INCOME PILOTS AND WE
SHARED THAT DATA WITH COMEDIAN
WELL. GIVEN THE LAST DOLLAR
TEACHER THIS PRO. AS WELL AS THE
- IN PRO A WAR JUST. BASED ON
THE BUT APPROPRIATE TO THE CLASS
. PROGRAM MISTER NAY COMMISSION
CAN ONLY ESTIMATE THE AWARD FOR
EACH STUDENT RECIPIENT. ONCE WE
KNOW SEVERAL POINTS. FIRST THE
TOTAL OF IT WILL. BASED ON THE
NUMBER. STUDENTS AND THE TOTAL
TO PROTECT. NEXT THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING A PER. TOWARDS THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. AND THEN THIRD AND
PERHAPS MOST CHALLENGING. ALL
OTHER FORMS OF EIGHTY EACH
STUDENT WILL RECEIVE INCLUDING
THAT STUDENTS INSTITUTIONAL
EIGHT AWARDS THAT COME FROM THE
UC AND CSU CAMPUSES. AT WHICH
TURN ROLLED. MR NATE CAN FINALLY
THAT CALL ESTIMATE WAIT TO AND I
JUST KNOW. AND WE SAW THE PER
FUNDING AMOUNT FOR THIS UPCOMING
BUDGET YOU'RE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PRESENTED ON JANUARY.
RIGHT NOW HELP STUDENTS ARE
STILL APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL
AID- THROUGH MARCH SECOND THE
PRIORITY DEADLINE FOR CALIFORNIA
TITLE MATCH TOMORROW- BUT WE
ANTICIPATE THAT AN EXTENSION OF
THAT DEADLINE UNTIL PEOPLE
FIRST. IT'S VERY LIKELY GOOD
APPEALS FROM INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION AND K. TWELVE
DISTRICTS BE APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSION. EVEN THE IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC ON APPLICATION
SUPPORT AGENT AND DECREASED
APPLICATION RIGHT. SEE IF YOU
WHEN YOU SEE CAN DATA TO THIS TO
MAKE AADHAR STAFF THAT THEY WILL
ONLY BE ABLE TO SHARE
INSTITUTIONAL DATA ONCE THEY
HAVE PASSED THEIR ADMISSIONS
DEADLINE AND UNDERSTOOD THE
IMPACT OF ENROLLMENT DECISIONS.
ON INSTITUTIONAL EIGHT AWARDS.
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION WOULD
HAVE RECEIVED THAT DATA IN JULY.
AT WHICH POINT WE COULD
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT OF
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT AWARDS FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. THIS MEANS THAT THE
STUDENT COMMISSION AND ARE.
UNIVERSITY PARK MAY BE ABLE TO.
THE ABOUT THEIR LAST ALLEGED FOR
MIDDLE CLASS. AWARD DURING THIS
FOR. WE WOULD NOT TO DEAL
AVAILABLE TO A PRECISE AWARD
AMOUNT FOR EACH OF THOSE
UNIVERSITY. UNTIL THE STOCK. AND
THIS IS TRUE NOT ONLY FOR THIS
FIRST YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION.
REALLY WILL BE TRUE OF ANY
FUTURE HERE UNTIL. A DIFFERENT
MECHANISM FOR DIFFERENT TIMELINE
AND IN PLACE. FOR WHEN YOU SEE
IF THE ISSUE CAMPUSES COULD
SHARE THAT MOMENT AND
INSTITUTIONAL A DATA. WITH THIS
TO MAKE. OKAY AND CAN YOU GO
OVER WHAT THE- UPPER INCOME
LIMITS ARE NOW FOR. THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP RECIPIENTS.
YES SURE I BELIEVE THAT THE
UPPER INCOME LIMIT FOR THIS YEAR
IS A HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. STATURE AND
SO THIS- THIS THIS REALLY SETS
US UP IN THE IN THE FUTURE TO
HELP MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES NOT
JUST FOR TUITION BUT ALSO. NON
TUITION COSTS. SO WHAT MORE DO
WE NEED TO. COORDINATE BETWEEN
THIS AND OUR CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
TO MAKE IT SEAMLESS WE DON'T
NEED THAT PHD TO UNDERSTAND HOW
TO APPLY FOR FINANCIAL. THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION AND
ONE WE DIDN'T THINKING ABOUT
QUITE A BIT AS YOU'D IMAGINE-
RIGHT NOW ALL- AS YOU NOTED THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP AND
ELIGIBILITY CEILING WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THAT.
GRAHAM FOR A FAMILY OF THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS INCOME CEILING
ABOUT TEN DOLLARS. SO THIS MEANS
THAT- REALLY MOST DO YOU SEE AND
CSU STUDENTS FOR SPEAKING TO.
WHAT ALSO. BE RECEIVING A CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WORK ON THEIR- THE
PIECE THAT GETS HERE IS THAT
THERE WILL STILL BE STUDENTS
MORE LOWER INCOME OR MIDDLE
INCOME. AND FOR ONE REASON OR
ANOTHER ARE LIMITED IN THEIR
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA BASED ON
THOSE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IN OUR
PRIOR AGENDA ITEM. SO THIS
REALLY CREATED SOME COMPLEXITY
PRESS AT THE STATE MADE
COMMISSION IN COMMUNICATING THE
AID THAT THE STUDENT WOULD
RECEIVE UNDER BOTH PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE YOU HELP STUDENTS WITH
ACADEMIC INCOME PROFILES BUT
BASED ON THOSE NON FINANCIAL-
BARRIERS STUDENTS MADE JUST
GETTING THEM IN CLASS. WORK AND
NOT ALSO THE CALTRAIN WORK THAT
WOULD HELP COVER THEIR TUITION.
WE BELIEVE IT PUBLIC RECORD
WOULD HELP SIMPLIFY THE MESSAGE
THAT WE CAN SEND TO LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME STUDENTS SO THAT
WE CAN INFORM THEM THAT THEY'LL
BE GETTING GUARANTEED COOL
TUITION COVERAGE. THROUGH THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS AND THAT THAT
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM CAN HELP FURTHER OFFSET
THEIR NON. TUITION EXPENSES. AND
THEN IT MUCH WOULD WE- WOULD WE
- TO- TO FIND PROPOSAL TO TAKE
FOR. FULL BLACK OF BETTER TERM
DEBT FREE COLLEGE GRANTS TO
ENABLE. CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
RECIPIENTS TO WORK. FIFTEEN
HOURS A WEEK LIKE WE TALKED
ABOUT TO HAVE THE- EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION BASED UPON.
IS THERE AN ISSUE WITH MY-
NUMBER OF PEOPLE- I'M SORRY IF.
THAT'S OKAY EIGHT HOW MUCH WILL
BE NEEDED TO PROVIDE THE DEBT
FREE COLLEGE GRANTS TO BASED
UPON THIS SCENARIO WHERE
STUDENTS WORK FIFTEEN HOURS A
WEEK YOU HAVE THE EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION BASED UPON
YOU KNOW THEIR FINANCIAL WHERE
WITH ALL. AND YOU HAVE THE
EXISTING FINANCIAL AID AWARDS
HOW MUCH MORE WE NEED. TO
PROVIDE AT A DEBT FREE COLLEGE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. THE FULLY
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM AS IT WAS REVISED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACT WITH THAT
REMARK IN MIND GERMAN CURTI THE
COST THAT WE ARE PROJECTED WITH
TWO POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
ABOUT THE PRIOR APPROPRIATION.
AND SO THAT LEAVES YOU WITH MINE
I THOUGHT WOULD PROVIDE LAST
YEAR WHICH IS. JUST NORTH OF A
BILLION. I I'M TRYING TO. THINK
OF THE MAP HERE IT'S TWO POINT
SIX BILLION FOR FULL
IMPLEMENTATION YOU HAVE SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO. MILLION
PROPOSED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
SO ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS ABOUT WHAT'S
BEEN PROPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THAT MEASURE THAT'S
APPLES TO APPLES BECAUSE THE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION THIS YEAR IS
JUST. FOR THIS YEAR'S I THINK
THERE'S COMMITTED TO ANY OTHER
BASED UPON THE A GROUP THE
FRAMEWORK AGREEMENT LAST YEAR.
HOW MUCH MORE WOULD BE INCLUDED
I DON'T THINK IT'S TWO BILLION.
CAN YOU GET BACK TO US WITH THAT
WITH THAT WITH THOSE NUMBERS.
I'M HAPPY TO DO SO YEAH. OKAY
THANK YOU SLIMMER REST. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED I HAVE ONE CONCERN AND
VALUES THAT OFTENTIMES. WELL
REALLY THE STUDENTS THAT WERE
MOST LOOKING AT OUR THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE MOST DISADVANTAGED THE
ONES OF THE HARDEST TIME PAYING
FOR THEIR TUITION. IF WE HAVE
CAL GRANT WITH ITS ISSUES WE NOW
HAVE THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP THE BASICALLY
SUPPLEMENTS BUT IF OUR
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS DON'T GET
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF EVERYTHING
UNDER CAL GRANT BECAUSE OF THOSE
ITEMS THAT YOU'VE NOTED. THEY
ARE EVEN MORE DISADVANTAGED.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION THE
TEMPORARY SOLUTION THAT WE CAN
DO AS THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE
CARE OF THIS EVEN IF IT'S
TEMPORARY WHILE WE LOOK TO
CORRECT IT'S COMPLETELY.
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER THAT'S
SUCH AN IMPORTANT POINT IN THIS
DISCUSSION AND WHY WE BELIEVE
THAT THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
BUT IT'S SO CRITICAL THAT- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS- IT DOES
WORK FOR DEBT FREE COLLEGE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
THAT CLEAR MESSAGE TO STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES THAT IF YOU'RE
BELOW THIS DEFINED INCOME
THRESHOLD. WE'RE GOING TO COVER
YOUR TUITION AND THAT THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMMING
INSTITUTIONAL AID WILL HELP
FURTHER OFF THAT ALL OF THOSE
OTHER NON TUITION COSTS THAT WE
DISCUSSED IN OUR PRIOR AGENDA
ITEM WE THINK THAT. IN A
STATEMENT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE TO
LOWER. STUDENTS AND THEY HAVE.
WHO CURRENT RIGHT NOW DON'T HAVE
THAT GUARANTEED. ACCESS
SITUATION COVERAGE TO BE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS IT WOULD ONLY SEE
A PERCENTAGE OF THEIR WORK BE
COVERED TO THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP FOR. SO SHORT OF IT%
IF I MOVED THROUGH THE CHAIR. SO
SHORT OF JUST TELLING THEM
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
EVERYTHING. MY SPECIFIC QUESTION
IS WHAT CAN WE DO. IT I THINK
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE DISSERVICE IF
WE ARE PUTTING SO MUCH MONEY
INTO MIDDLE. CLASS SCHOLARSHIP.
WHICH IS IT'S LAUDABLE. BUT IF
WE'RE NOT TAKING CARE OF THE
STUDENTS WHO NEED IT THE MOST.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T TAKEN CARE OF
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE I THINK
IT'S A DISSERVICE TO THE ONES
WHO DEPEND ON US MOST TO HELP
THEM PAY FOR THIS TUITION AND
RELATED EXPENSES. SO SHORT OF
JUST TELLING THEM YOU KNOW
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
EVERYTHING YOU NEED- MAYBE WILL
TAKE CARE OF IT LATER WHAT CAN
WE AS A LEGISLATURE DO NOW TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THIS IS TAKEN
CARE OF BEFORE WE START PUTTING
IN SO MUCH MONEY INTO THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. YEAH
AND WE ABSOLUTELY SHARED- THAT
SENTIMENT AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE'RE MAKING PATHWAYS
AFFORDABLE FOR ALL STUDENTS WERE
NOT LEAVING BEHIND THIS
POPULATION THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING
TO MAJORITY LEADER. AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY A QUESTION FOR WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR-
WISHED YOU- DEDICATE FUNDS AND
HOW YOU WANT TO BUILD ON THE
INVESTMENT THAT WERE AGREED UPON
LAST YEAR. AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
NOT SID BELABOR THE POINT WHERE
WE HAD THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION ARE ARE SO I'M
INVESTED IN THE CONCEPT OF CAL
GRANT REPORT. IT REMOVES THOSE
REMAINING BARRIERS TO KEEP OUT
LOGIN STUDENTS- THERE ARE OTHER
PROPOSALS YOU CAN CONSIDER THAT
WOULD BE. HELPFUL LESS DIRECTED
AND LYFT SYSTEMATIC APPROACHES
IN THAT WOULDN'T REALLY PROVIDE.
GUARANTEED ACCESS TO STUDENTS IN
THE OUT YEARS OR CREATE THAT
KIND OF CLEAR COHESIVE SYSTEM
THAT WE REALLY WANT TO
COMMUNICATE FOR STUDENTS. SO
FINALLY IF I MAY CHAIR. SO
BEFORE WE PUT THE ONE. DOLLARS
IN THE CLASS. IT SOUNDS LIKE IN
RESPONSE TO. TERROR MCCARTY'S
QUESTION IT WAS 200-523-0050
MILLION. NO ONE ON GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF THE ISSUES IN THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR THE MOST.
DISADVANTAGE THE MOST OF IT YOU
NEED OF ASSISTANCE. IS THAT
CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT AND I
WOULD JUST NOTE ALSO THAT ANY
DOLLARS YOU PUT INTO THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT GO OUT TO
YOU SEE AND SEE IF YOU STUDENTS
I'VE TOLERATE AWARDS FOR THOSE
STUDENTS THAT ACTUALLY BUYS DOWN
YOUR CALL. ON THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM BECAUSE THEN
THERE'S THAT MUCH LESS OF A GAP
IN UNMET FINANCIAL NEED THAT THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
WOULD BE COVERING SO IN A WAY
YOU'RE PREPAYING TOWARDS MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP IMPLEMENTATION
WELL YOU ARE ALSO DIRECTING
RESOURCES TO THOSE LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS WERE SO OFTEN KEPT OUT
AND. THOSE ELIGIBILITY BITTERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I THINK
THE PICTURE HERE IS AS WE KNOW.
IT'S UNCERTAIN HOW MUCH MONEY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE IN THE BUDGET
AFTER THE MAY REVISED REVENUE
NUMBERS COME OUT. AND WE GET OF
COURSE YOU KNOW ALLOCATIONS FOR
EACH SUB COMMITTEE IN THE
SOMETHING SOMETHING FOR A
PRIORITY SO LET'S SAY WE HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I
THINK WE SEE THAT. ASK THIS TO
NAY COMMISSION LEADERS AS WHAT
HOW DO WE FOCUS ON OUR BIGGEST
BANG FOR OUR BUCK EVEN THOUGH
IT'S TWO BILLION TO GET OUR
DREAM SYSTEM. IF WE GET A
QUARTER OF THAT THIS YEAR AND
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE HELP
THAT THE STUDENTS THE NEEDIEST
STUDENTS LIKE. THIS REYES SAID
WHO SLIPPED THROUGH THE CRACKS
AND- YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
STUDENTS WHO. GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL ON TIME HAVE IT TOGETHER
THEY FIGURE IT OUT AND THEY HAVE
PARENTS AND FAMILIES FIGURED
OUT. IT'S A STUDENTS WHO WE WANT
TO HELP THE MOST TO. GO BACK TO
SCHOOL FIVE YEARS LATER. WE'RE
IN THE WORK FORCE SO THE PEOPLE
WE NEED TO GET COLLEGE DEGREES
AND- AND TO THE JOBS OF TODAY
AND TOMORROW. SO THOSE ARE THE
ONES THAT WERE. FAILING AND
SELL. THESE LOOPHOLES IN THAT WE
WHICH WE SYSTEMATICALLY EXCLUDE
PEOPLE. THOSE ARE THE ONES I
THINK ARE THE LOW HANGING FRUIT
THAT WE SHOULD TACKLE- TACKLE
FIRST- MR ADAN. YES THANK YOU
AND PERSONA ZERO FREE THE FACT
WE HAVE. THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP. TO ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING DYNAMICS I FACES
LEGISLATURE. IS THAT IT DOESN'T
PAY ENOUGH ATTENTION TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS THIS IS WHY MY
PARTY LOSES BECAUSE WE DO NOT
PAY. ATTENTION TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS- SO AGAIN- YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN A BIG PROPONENT OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP BECAUSE
IT IS THE ONE THING- MANY THAT
ACTUALLY A FEW ACTUALLY THAT-
PAYS ATTENTION TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS. QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR THE L.
A. M. AT THE HIGH END OF THE
INCOME AND ASSET MAXIMUM IS ONE
HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND. FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP IS
THERE A THRESHOLD ON THE LOWER
END. TO ACCESS THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP. YEAH I'M SORRY HE
DOES START TO QUESTION AND THEN
IF MY COLLEAGUES ARE FINANCE OF
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION I THINK
THEY MAY WISH THAT ON AS WELL.
UNDER CURRENT VERSION OF THE
PROGRAM THAT THIS UNIVERSE OF
THE HEALTHCARE BEIJING NOT
RECEIVING THE SCHOLARSHIP
HOWEVER UNDER THE PROVIDE
PROGRAM WILL TAKE IN TWENTY TWO
TO THREE STUDENTS RECEIVE BOTH.
HELPING TO CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
RIGHT AND SO THERE IS NO FOR
RECEIVING A MIDDLE CLASS
PROGRAMMING DEVICE VERSION OF
THE PROGRAM AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS RECEIVED LITTLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP AS A SUPPLEMENT TO
THAT HOW CAN AFFORD. OKAY MY
CONCERN. WOULD BE THAT WE HAVE
MONEY FOR MIDDLE CLASS NON AND
THAT IT NOT BE. YOU KNOW A
EVERYBODY CAN ACCESS ACCESS TO
THAT'S NOT. JUST FOR THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE MEDICAL. FOUR
OR IN EFFECT WATERING IT DOWN.
AND IN THE PAST THERE TO- SO.
JUST SOMETHING FOR PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM TONIGHT I WANT TO HELP
LOWER INCOME PEOPLE WERE DOING A
LOT OF THAT I BELIEVE THAT'S
WHAT MAKES AMERICA WORKS THERE'S
NOTHING MORE. CALIFORNIAN THAN
THAT. BUT AT THE SAME TIME- WE
WANT. TO SUPPORT THE MIDDLE
CLASS AS WELL WHO OFTEN DOES NOT
SUPPORT FEEL SUPPORTED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY THANK YOU. SEE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM
WE WILL HOLD THE ISSUE OPEN AND
PROCEED WITH THE ISSUE. NUMBER.
THREE WHICH ARE VARIOUS STATE
AID CAN MENTION BUDGET PROPOSALS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND ONGOING GENERAL FUND
AND FIVE POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE NEW PROGRAMS ESTABLISHED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
AND TO ADDRESS THE STAFFING
NEEDS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ONE TIME.
GENERAL FUND. TO EXPAND AND
SUPPLEMENT EXISTING CASPER
COLLEGE REGION COORDINATED
ORGANIZATIONS. ALSO THE GOVERNOR
BUDGETS INCLUDE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO MODIFY THE KALRA
BEACH FAMOUS SERVICE INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM. WE RESPECT
DISCIPLINE STEPHENS FROM THE
LABELING OF A TEN DOLLAR HOURLY
WAGE THE QUIBBLING OF A FIFTY
DOLLAR. WAY IT TO AUTHORIZE IT
EXPEND FONG. TO BE PROVIDED TO
YOU SEE NCSU TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA BEEN LOAN PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU NOT. BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY YOU.
L. A. THANK YOU ARE COMING YOU
YOUR HAIR DONE ON CAGE. FOR A
NEW POSITION. KENSHIN'S EVEN TO
STUDENT AID COMMISSION FINE AID
PROGRAMS LOOK AT THE COMPLEXITY
OF SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS WE
THINK THE REASON THING STAFFING
AT THE STUDENT COMMISSION AND WE
RECOMMEND A PER BECAUSE PROPOSED. TO YOU NEED COMMISSION COUNSEL
REQUEST. TWENTY TWO PER IN A- TO
THE FACT THAT SHINSUKE IN THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET. THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO WITH AND THE FURNACE
TO. DIFFERENCE THE WARREN.
INSURANCE QUALIFICATION OF
PROGRAMMING. WITHIN THE. THE
CUSTOMER. THE NEW REQUIREMENT
FOR SCHOOL TO VERIFY THE SCHOOL
ARE UP IN APPLE. LIKELY WILL TO
FOR THE CASH COLLEGE FIND AID OR
- AND HERE TO BE RECOMMENDED THE
PROPOSED ONE TIME. YOU KNOW THE
APPLICATION IN ONGOING IN NATURE
SO IF YEARS PLEDGES MAY ALSO TO
CONVEY THOUGHT FUNDING FOR
RECALL. YOUR STUDENTS PROTESTING
THE PROGRAM. ANOTHER REDIRECT
EXPENDED FUNDS TO THE DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY HIS IN
CSU. HOSTING FRIEDMAN WORD OF
MOUTH IS EVERY WAY TO ENCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION IN A PROGRAM THAT
CURRENTLY UNDER SUBSCRIBED. THE
CURRENT LAW OTHER PROGRAMS
FUNDING LEVEL IS SUFFICIENT TO
SUPPORT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS AS OF LAST FALL ONLY
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED STUDENTS
PROTEST. ONE OF THE MAIN REASON
FOR THIS YOU NEED QUESTIONS I
DON'T FOR THE LUCRATIVE RATE IS
THAT STUDENTS. ABLE TO FIND
BETTER PAYING WORK OPPORTUNITIES
ELSEWHERE. I'M THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BY PROVIDING THE
EQUIVALENT FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE FOR
STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROGRAM. WE HAVE A LOT OF TO
COMPENSATE STUDENTS RIGHT IT'S
MORE SIMILAR TO WHAT THEY COULD
RECEIVE. THROUGH THESE OTHER
WORK OPPORTUNITIES. WE
RECOMMENDED THE GOVERNOR'S
BECAUSE INCREASE WORD ON HOW
BACK. TO THE MARKET OF THAT WILL
TO PART TIME TO GET A. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED LANGUAGE
PART TIME STUDENT WOULD COME THE
THING THIRTY HOURS RECEIVED OF.
FOR MEETING THE REST ROLLED TIME
WE BE RECEIVE A COUPLE AS
DOLLARS A FIFTY CENTS AN HOUR.
WE DON'T FEEL STRONG RATIONALE
FOR COMPANY PART CAN AT A LOW
HOURLY RATE SO RECOMMEND
REMOVING THE- OF AWARDS. PART
FINALLY BECAUSE THE READER OF ON
FUNDS TO DREAMLAND. IF YOU IF
YOU LOOK AT THAT THANK. ARI TO
MEET DEMAND IN THE DREAMLAND
PROGRAM AT CURRENT LEVEL. OVER
THE MONTH ON THE- FOR PRETTY. AT
UC. FOR THE THREE WE- DON'T THE
RATIONALE FOR. ADDITIONAL FUND
TO FOURTEEN THAT'S AND BACK MY
PROJECT BACK. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TRAIL BILL LANGUAGE. THANK YOU
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE A CLASS A
DIFFERENT BRAND TACK. AND THEN.
OKAY THANK YOU- THANK YOU.
SENATE COMMISSION. HE CAN IS AT
ALL ALL THE WITH THE- BUT
PROPOSAL AROUND FOR FACT THAT.
NEEDS AND ALL BEGIN BY NOTE THAT
THE CAN VERY FOR THE PURPOSE
STAFF AUTHORITY IN DID YOU-
FUNDING THAT PROVIDED IN THE
COMING PROPOSED BUDGET HOWEVER
AS THE LEGISLATIVE AND ALL NOTED
- HE- ARE ONLY IF OF THE PER THE
THAT WE WERE. I OF THE FULL
TWENTY SEVEN POSITION- BEEN
REQUESTED BY THE STUDENT
COMMISSION AND ASSOCIATED WITH
FOUR DOLLARS AND GOING. ITS
REQUEST FOR INVESTMENT INTEREST
. AND CAPACITY. WITH MADE IN OUR
- OF SICK. WORK INCREASES THE
HAVE COME UP AS WERE. OF YEAR'S
ACTS. AND OTHER POLICY MAY LAST
YEAR. THERE'S BEEN HIGH SCHOOL.
AID REQUIREMENT WITH ARE VERY
EXCITED TO SEE COME ONLINE THIS
UP YEAR- WHAT WILL MEAN THAT
THERE'S NOT ONLY MORE STUDENTS
APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL AID- BUT
THERE ALSO BE MORE QUESTIONS
COMING FROM STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES TO THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. AND MORE. FOR OUR
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES THAT ARE
TRYING TO HELP THEIR STUDENTS
APPLY. WE ALL KNOW AS WE SPOKE
ABOUT HER AND- TO HEARING. THE
NATIONAL CALIBER AT RECIPIENTS
FOR DO YOU NEED. TO AND SERVE
UNDER THE NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ENTITLEMENT. LAST YEAR TO
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ADOPTED
A CO WORK BASED TUITION SYSTEM
THAT WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
IMPLEMENT AND PROCESS AND MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO OUR WORKING
SYSTEM SO THAT WE'RE PROVIDING A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF CALTRAIN
AWARD TO STUDENTS BASED ON THE
YEAR WHICH STANDS. WE ALREADY
DISCUSSED THE LARGER AND MORE
COMPLEX MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE GOING TO
START IMPLEMENTING THIS YEAR.
AND FINALLY- I ALREADY MENTIONED
EARLIER AT THE FORTHCOMING
CHANGES TO THE FEDERAL
APPLICATION SYSTEM FOR FINANCIAL
AID AND WHILE THAT DOESN'T
REQUIRE STATUTORY CHANGES IT
DOES REQUIRE TECHNICAL CHANGES
ON OUR PART AT THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. TO ALIGN OUR WORK
SYSTEM WITH THE NEW DATA WILL BE
RECEIVING TO THE FEDERAL EIGHT
APPLICATIONS AS WELL AS TO BE A
CORRESPONDING CHANGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT APPLICATION
. AT THE LEGISLATURE ANALYST'S
NOTED THE STUDENT COMMISSION SAW
SIXTY. AND IN THE AMOUNT OF THE
LISTED FUNDS. THERE WERE MANY
BUT THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
YEAR. AND THE LEVEL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET CARE
FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. LAST
YEAR ALONE THERE IS AN INCREASE
IN OVERALL ONE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT IF YOU NEED COMMISSION IS
MANAGING. WHAT THE COMES
SIGNIFICANT NOT ONLY OUR PROGRAM
STAFF BUT ALSO ADMINISTRATIVE I.
AND FINANCIAL STAFF. THAT HELPED
OVERSEE OUR CONTRACTING PROGRAM
BUDGET STUDENT APPLICATION
PORTALS AND OTHER ADMINISTRATIVE
STATE REPORTING MECHANISMS.
MOVING TOWARD- THE- ATTACHED FOR
COLLEGE FOR- I'LL BE BRIEF HERE
THESE ARE ONE TIME FUNDS THAT
WILL HELP THIS UNIQUE AND
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO WORK H.
WALKER. AS THEIR IMPLEMENTING
FINANCIAL AID COME REQUIREMENTS
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MAJORITY LEADER ASK FOR
LEADERSHIP AND THAT CALL A LOT
MORE FOR STUDENTS APPLY FOR
FINANCE AID BUT WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE SUPPORT
PARTICULARLY IN THE EARLY STAGES
OF IMPLEMENTATION. SO WE'VE
IDENTIFIED REGIONS WHERE WE
WOULD LIKE TO ESTABLISH- WHAT WE
WERE AS COURT OFFICES OR
ENTITIES THAT WORK WITH LOCAL
SCHOOL- AND IF THE TWO OF HIGHER
. AND OTHER PARTNERS TO PROVIDE
TO STUDENTS AND TO SCHOOL ARE
THE APPLICATIONS FINANCIAL AID.
AND FINALLY MOVE TO THE
PRECURSOR INSIDE GRANT FOR- WORK
VERY GREAT THE EMBLEM THIS PER
IN OUR PROVIDE A DOCK. STEVE
WITH GREATER ACCESS TO FINANCIAL
AID AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THREE COMMUNITY
SERVICE. AND WE'RE ALSO
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROPOSED
CHANGES IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
BUDGET. TO HELP ADDRESS WANT THE
ISSUES THAT WE GET THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. I HAVE HEARD.
FROM OUR- PARTNER OVER THE SPURS
YEAR TRUE IMPLEMENTATION. WE
ALSO AGREED THE L. A. RECORD.
BUT THIS REPORTER PURPOSE THAT
RESULT IN REDUCING ALL WORKS FOR
PART TIME ENROLLED STUDENTS.
SHOULD BE REMOVED THIS IS BEEN
ANOTHER CONSISTENT POINT OF VIEW
FROM HER. PARTNERS ABOUT HOW
STUDENTS RESPONDED TO THE TOPIC
. WHEN IT'S PRESENTED TO THEM.
AND WHILE WE GET THIS YOU NEED
TO. DON'T ADMINISTER BETWEEN
LOAN PROGRAM AND THE CAMPUS IS
FOR YOU SEEN FEW IF YOU WOULD.
BETTER DATA FOR YOU WHAT THIS I
WOULD JUST NOTE A COUPLE OF THE
FACTORS THAT LMAO POINTED TO IN
THERE NOW- THAT HAVE IMPACTED
PARTICIPATE IN THE DREAM PROGRAM
. THE PAST FEW YEARS. MAYBE
FACTORS AS MORE STUDENTS SHIPPED
BACK TO ON CAMPUS LIVING STATUS.
AND WE NO LONGER SEE FURTHER
INVESTMENT IN EMERGENCY AID- AS
A RESULT OF THE COOKER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IT'S BEEN OFFICE TODAY
. THREE FUNDING THE STUDENTS
WERE. THOSE BACKED MIGHT WORST
TO SYDNEY DREAM OF AND THE NEXT
YEARS I THAT CHANGE. OKAY THANK
YOU. I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ON THESE- MISCELLANEOUS BUDGET
ITEMS THING NINE I WILL GO TO
NUMBER FOUR LET TO. FOR STUDENTS
THIS A- INFORMATIONAL ITEM ABOUT
THE REPORT AND SOME WORK AT THE
SCENE COMMISSION DID. TO TRY TO
GET- MORE STUDENTS- LINKED UP TO
THE CALPERS PROGRAM TO HELP WITH
IT HUNGER NEEDS IN JUST OVERALL
COST CALL SO. AS COMMISSION HAVE
PLEASE- PROCEED WITH YOUR
FINDINGS. THANK YOU YOUR MCCARTY
IN A PRETTY THE OP TO PRESENT
YOU TODAY ON- ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE KNOW IT'S REALLY BEEN
WIDESPREAD AND A GROWING
CHALLENGE AT OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES- AS I THINK THIS
COMMITTEES WELL AWARE- STUDENTS
REPORTING THAT THEY ARE FOOD
INSECURE AND OFTEN GOING HUNGRY.
THERE'S CERTAIN SURVEYS THAT
THAT YOU NEED COMMISSION IS
CONDUCTED WE FOUND ONE OUT OF
THREE STUDENTS REPORT BEING FOOD
INSECURE AND FURTHER SURVEYS WE
FOUND THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC
STUDENTS ARE REPORTING THAT
THERE. COSTS HAVE ACTUALLY. AND
I. RELATIVELY COLLEGE STUDENTS
RECEIVED FRESH BENEFITS FOR
WHICH THEY CALL QUALIFY. WHAT
DATA IS LIMITED IMAGE AREA AND
I'LL COME BACK TO THAT POINT
LATER ONE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ISSUED A REPORT
ON THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
ESTIMATED TO RECEIVE CALFRESH.
THEY FOUND A HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS LIKELY
IN ROLES. HOWEVER THAT IS OUT
OF. FOR HUNDREDS WITH MAKE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS. THAT ARE LIKELY
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CALPERS TRIMS
RAM. IT'LL PROMPT OUT THAT THIS
AID TO A WORKER AND FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY. THAT INCLUDED
STUDENTS CAMPUS BAY NEEDS
LEADERS RESEARCH EXPERTS AND
STOP COUNTY AT A- AND THE LEAD.
TO HELP US BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S TO ARE NOT ACCESS THIS
BENEFIT AND IDENTIFIED THE NEED
FOR WHICH WE CAN. CONNECT THEM
TO CALIFORNIA. TODAY I WILL
BRIEFLY SHARE A FEW WITH THE
LOVE TAKEAWAY AND RICK. AND IN A
REPORT THAT THE FACT BECAUSE
WITHIN THE NEXT WEEK ACTUALLY SO
THIS IS A PREVIEW. OF WHAT WILL
BE PUTTING OUT VERY SOON. FIRST
WHY ARE SO FEW COLLEGE STUDENTS
RECEIVING CALFRESH. WE HAVE TO
OF COURSE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
FEDERAL LAW AND REGULATIONS WERE
SPECIFIC STRUCTURED TO KEEP
STUDENTS OUT OF THE SNAP PROGRAM
THAT WE REFER TO AS CALFRESH IN
CALIFORNIA. STUDENTS MUST
ACTUALLY. QUALIFY FOR AN
EXEMPTION IN ORDER TO APPLY. AN
EXTRA OF PROOF ON STUDENT TO
NOT- ONLY APPLY AND MEET FINANCE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIRED THAN ANY
OTHER. DOES FOR THE PROGRAM BUT
ALSO DAMAGED AN ENSURE THAT
THEIR COUNTY OFFICE RECORD.
THEIR EXEMPTION FROM THE FUNERAL
. AND OF COURSE THIS MEANS THAT
EACH TIME THAT THERE IS A CHANGE
IN POLICY AND HOW STUDENT
APPLICATIONS ARE PROCESSED
WORKOUT. LATER THAT RESULTS FROM
FEDERAL OR STATE GUIDANCE THIS
MUST BE COMMUNICATED ACROSS
AGENCY IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. WHICH CAN RESULT
INCONSISTENT IMPLEMENTATION OF
CHANGES LIKE ALLOWING FOR
STUDENTS FILL START HERE. FROM
THE STUDENT. THERE ARE OTHER YOU
NEED TO ASK OF STATE PARK. THAT
HAVE MADE THEIR ACCESS CALFRESH
MORE TO. STUDENTS ARE POPULATION
THERE OFTEN MOVING FROM ONE
COUNTY TO ANOTHER AS THEY
TRANSITION TO PERFECT. EDUCATION
AND THAT'S MADE A COUNTY BASED
SYSTEM IT'S COMPLICATED MECCA.
FOR TRANSFERRING THE CHALLENGE.
THE NATURE OF THE ACADEMIC YEAR
AND THE TRAINING OF WEDNESDAY
MOVED NEW COUNTY ALSO. A LARGE
RECURRING SEASONAL. AND
APPLICATION. I THE BALL AND MAKE
SURE. MANY COUNTIES WITH LARGE
STUDENT POPULATIONS FEEL WAVE
APPLICATION HIT AT THE SAME TIME
. THIS CREATES REAL. ISSUE FIRST
THAT RESULTS IN LONGER PROCESS
AND WAIT. FIRST YOU HAVE TO. BUT
I'VE TALKED ON THE ISSUE THE
HINDERS ACTS TO CAL. I WILL
BRIEFLY SHARE SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDED THAT ARE. BY TO HELP
BETTER. STUDENTS AND- THE FOR
YOU ARE REALLY OPPORTUNE FOR
STATE TO BE AND IF THEY DO AND
UP NEW APPROACHES THAT WOULD
HELP PROMOTE STUDENT ACCESS TO
CALFRESH. BURST WE GET PAID THE
USE OF REGIONAL OF. THAT CONCERN
BUT I THE CURRENT DO THE TRASH
PROGRAM FOR AN- THAT WOULD HAVE
A SPECIFIC A SPECIALLY TRAINED
TEAM UP COUNTY ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS THAT FOCUS ON PROCESS
STEVEN APPLICATION. FOR MANY
STUDENT WITHIN THAT COMES OF
COUNTY. HELLO ALSO. NEXT OF THE
ACCESS FOR IMMIGRANT AND ON TOP
COMMUNITY. WE WOULD RECKON
CONSIDER YOU OF- ON A PILOT
BASIS USE OF THE TREE BACKED UP
. ARTISTS UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
BETTER ALREADY- AND TO THE STATE
FOR. PURPOSES THIS COULD ALL SIR
AT THE PRIME OR THE GOVERNMENT
TAKING MAKING SAME SHE- SO THAT
ONCE YOU SUBMIT A FAX UP AND
APPLY FOR FEDERAL AID. THEY CAN
BE CAN PERSPECTIVE. OF
SUBMITTING ADDITION APPLE. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE LEVERAGE-
BETTER AND IN THE FUTURE WAYS.
FIRST CALIFORNIA START TO TRACK
ACTUAL. AND NOT AS- STEVE APPLE
. AND ACCEPT INTO THE CALFRESH
FROM. WE ALSO LOOK SEE HOW WE
CAN AT LEAST PRE POPULATE A
CALPERS CHAPEL PATIENT WITHOUT
THE DATA TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
REDUNDANT. WE ASK PEOPLE AS WELL
AS USED READ REVIEWS PRESIDENT
DATA WORKING BALLPARK. TO
IDENTIFY THAT ARE LIKELY FOR
CALFRESH AT THE TRANSITIONING
HIGHER TO. AND OF COURSE WE HAVE
TO SUPPORT COUNTY AND THEY'RE
WORKING PROCESSING. HIS
APPLICATION. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING FORMULA
FOR COUNTIES. RECOGNIZE EXISTING
WORKLOADS. INCREASE FOR COUNTIES
BE. AND A CASES. WE MUST ALSO
HAVE BEEN COMMUNITY EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE. IMPLEMENTING
NEW ACCESS POLICIES FOR
STUDENTS. ALSO OF OUR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. AND BENEFITS ARE
ONLY OF STUDENTS TO BE THAT CAN
UTILIZE THAT WE SHOULD ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS CAN UTILIZE THEIR
CALFRESH BENEFITS ON CAMPUS. BY
DRUG COLLEGES IN YOUR- TO PUT
EBT CARDS I CAMPUS DINING
FACILITY. A GROWING NUMBER OF
CAMPUSES I'VE DONE THIS ALREADY
WE'RE TAKING STEPS TO DO SO BUT
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S MORE WOK
WE CAN DO HERE. SO BACK MY
REMARKS HERE BUT I'M OF COURSE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS. YEAH SO THIS GOES
BACK TO A DISTRO DONALD KIND OF
EARLIER ABOUT AID THE FOR PROFIT
. IT'S K. IS VERY SIMILAR NEEDED
PHD TO UNDER. HOW HOW TO APPLY
AND I KNOW WE YEAR AFTER YEAR
WERE OFFERING- PURSUING
LEGISLATION AND I'M- LIKE AGAIN
DO ONE OF THE BILLS HIS
RECOMMENDATION YEAR. WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S THE BIG PICTURE AS FAR AS
I MEAN IF YOU THOUGHT WHAT'S THE
EASIEST WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT
LOW INCOME STUDENTS THE WHEN
THEY'RE AT HOME IN NOT IN
COLLEGE OR THEIR- ARE FOR
CALFRESH AND GET IT. WE HAVE
THESE- YOU KNOW OTHER THINGS
THAT PEOPLE APPLY FOR WHICH YOU
KNOW THE FACT KIND OF. SHOW THAT
YOU'RE LOW INCOME. SO WHAT
STOPPING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FROM SAYING IF YOU'RE A PELL
GRANT RECIPIENT. AUTUMN
ELIGIBILITY FOR CALIFORNIA'S.
AND WHY OUT ALL THIS. HEADACHE
AND NONSENSE AND THAT IS IT. HI
THIS IS SOMETHING I'M MISSING
WITH THAT GREATLY INCREASED
ENTITLEMENT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IS
NEVER FIXED AMOUNT THAT YOU TAKE
ANYWAY SO HOW DOES THAT WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE. VERY QUESTION- I
THERE ARE SOME OUT ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT THE STUDENT POPULOUS-
STILL EXIST AND THE- IT SOME
PARTS OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND PARTICULARLY AMONG SOME
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THAT. THAT
BEING SAID I AM PLEASED TO SHARE
THAT CENTER ALEX BETHEA
CONGRESSMAN JIMMY GOMEZ FROM OUT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THEY ARE BOTH
WORK TO A- THAT ISSUE AND TO
MAKE. CHANGES TO YOUR FEDERAL
LAW AND REGULATIONS LIMITS
ACCESS TO THIS MAP PROGRAMMER
I'LL FOR SURE. SO THAT WE CAN
START GETTING CLOSER TO THAT
GOAL OF NOT ASKING A LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TO PROVE TIME AND TIME
AGAIN THAT THEY'RE WHAT INCOME
AND IT'S JUST. HER THEIR
INFORMATION WITH MULTIPLE
AGENCIES JUST TO GET THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED. TO COVER THEIR BASIC
NEEDS AFTER TRYING TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION SO THERE ARE
EFFORT UNDERWAY THERE HAVE BEEN
FOR SEVERAL YEARS. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SOME- AS
YOU KNOW PHILIP. DIFFERENCES
AMONG SOME OF THE MEMBER OF
CONGRESS I GET IT BUT LIKE FOR
IN CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE CALVIN RECIPIENTS AND SOME
RECEIVE THE PAL THE FEWEST A PAL
THAT BASICALLY IS THE FACT IT
MEANS YOU'RE- THE LOWER. OF LOW
INCOME ACOSTA HAS IT EVER BEEN
PROPOSED THAT HAVE. AUTOMATIC
FOR CALIFORNIA SNAP BENEFITS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR PARIS.
HAS THAT EVER BEEN. ON THE. SO
FAR MOST OF THE DISCUSS AND I'M
FOR. WITH THE FEDERAL LEVEL IS
REALLY RARE TRYING TO HELP. THE
ISSUE ROLE THAT KEEP STUDENTS
FOR APPLYING CALFRESH IN THE-
PLACE- BUT I WILL SAY WE HAD A
VERY POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
MEMBERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DELEGATION I JUST MENTIONED. WHO
ARE REALLY LOOKING EVEN FURTHER
NAP SAY YOU KNOW. WE STREAM THIS
. AND TO YOUR POINT. USE METRICS
BECOME FINANCE AID APPLICATIONS
UNDER THAT THE STUDENTS SHOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS OTHER FORM
OF SUPPORT. SO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE UNDER WAY NOW
BUT- UNFORTUNATELY WE STILL HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO ON THAT
FEDERAL LEVEL. YEAH YEAH MEAN WE
LOVE FIRST ARGUE CENTER MR
PADILLA AND- JIMMY GOMEZ A
FORMER. OF THIS ASSEMBLY BUT- IT
TAKES MUCH MORE THAN A TWO. AT
THE NATIONAL LEVEL TO MAKE THIS
A REALITY- WHAT. WHAT THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT PIECES OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT- WOULDN'T
HAVE THE IS MUCH OF A FINANCIAL
IMPACT THAT WE CAN DO RIGHT AWAY. ID LIKELY THAT WOULD BE-
CONSIDERING HOW WE CAN BETTER
LEVERAGE DATA AND START TO
ACTUALLY TRACK STUDENT
APPLICATIONS INTO THE PROGRAM
AND WHAT THE ENROLLMENT RATES
ARE WHAT MECHANISMS THERE ARE
FOUR CONNECTING K. TWELVE DATA-
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION DATA
WITH BURKE COUNTY OFFICES SO
THAT CAN TRY TO PRE POPULATE
SOME OF THE APPLICATIONS THAT
ARE GOING OUT- THOSE ARE. CRAP
LEFT AND THAT THE REQUIRE NEW ON
EXPENDITURE AWAY SOME OTHERS-
PROPOSAL MIGHT THERE DID
TECHNICALLY THAT AND WHEN WE OF
COURSE THE KNOWLEDGE THAT AND
THAT THERE ARE. TRANSACTION WAS
THAT THIS SERVICES AGENCIES ARE
MAKING IN THEIR DATA PLATFORMS
THAT WILL MAKE THIS- NOT A D. V.
BUT PERHAPS THAT'S LOWER COSTS.
THE OTHER OF COURSE THAT I WOULD
I WOULD HAVE TO CALL IT TEN TO
WOULD BE PILOT PRO WERE NOT CAN
THE STATE TO AND PEOPLE AND I
GOING. PROPOSAL BUT REALLY
TRYING NEW AND ENDED. LIKE THOSE
REACH HUB SO THAT WE CAN SEE IF
WE DO HAVE TEAM THAT UNDERSTAND
THESE SPECIAL RULES FOR STUDENT
APPLICATIONS AND- SHE WAS
CERTAINLY ARE QUITE IS DOWN BY
THE- LINE THE WAY THAT THE KERR
SYSTEM IS- WE THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER REAL IMPORTANT UPPER.
FOR US TO BETTER HOW WE SERVE
THESE. AND MANAGEABLE FROM A
COST PERSPECTIVE AND I'M FINE I
WOULD NOTE TRANSITIONING MORE
HURT IS- UNIVERSITIES TO BE A
EXTRA IT EVEN BETTER. IS ANOTHER
PIECE WHERE WE KNOW SOME
INSTITUTION ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS PROJECT- AND WE CAN
LEGISLATION OR SMALL TARGETED
PLANNING GRANTS COULD BE USEFUL
PER THAT. AS WELL. OKAY THANK
YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS FASTING
NINE THANK YOU FOR- PRESS TODAY
HOLD THIS IS OFTEN WE'RE GONNA
GO ON TO THE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
LIBRARY- IS THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE WE HAVE. BUDGET THAT FIFTH
HARMONY FINANCE. FINISH STATE
LIVE WILL. THE PRESENT TO US.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. COME
MISTER CHAIR AND I MEMBERS
JENNIFER WITH THE OF FINANCE THE
STATE LABOR AUGMENT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ARE CONTINUE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S EMPHASIS
ON ACCESS EQUITY AND INNOVATION
THEY GOT BUDGET PROPOSED EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION ONGOING
JOURNAL FINE AND ONE POINT FIVE
A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FERTILE
SUPPORT AUGMENTATION THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF THIRTY
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND TOTAL.
SIXTEEN LIKE GREEN BAY INCLUDE
DIGITIZATION OF SICK MATERIAL
FOR A TOTAL OF FORTY MILLION OF
WHICH TWELVE POINT SEVEN MILLION
AS MY TIME GENERAL FUND AND ONE
THREE MILLION AND ON TO TURN OUT
FINE AS WELL AS ONE OF THE
LIBRARY FOR NINE ON JOURNAL FUND
FOR AND RUN TOOK FOR THE LIFE
RECORDS TO A TWO POINT TWO
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND. OF
ONE TIME AND FOR STATE LIBRARY
INCLUDE DOCTOR AND FOR TO AT
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND WHICH IS A
CONTINUATION OF ONLINE
UPSKILLING AND PER TO SERVER TO
LIFE PEACH WHICH IS CURRENTLY BY
FROM FEDERAL AMERICAN BREAST
CANNOT OF TWENTY TWO ONE WE THE
ACTUAL MY PRIEST. I'M HAPPY TO
GO INTO ANY FURTHER AS REQUESTED
OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU L. L.
ARTISAN CONCENTRA SOLELY. UP FOR
THE WEIRD BACK MIND. BE HAVING A
CHEMICAL BUT HOPE YOU CAN SEE
STILL HEAR ME- SO I WOULD
DIRECTOR TO PAGE TWENTY THREE OF
YOUR AGENDA THAT LED THE FOR
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU TODAY. ARE
SUCH DIFFERS BRIDGE PROPOSALS
ALL GO THROUGH EACH ONE QUICKLY
. THIRTY WITHOUT FOURTEEN
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR-
DIGITIZATION ACTIVITIES WE THINK
THE OVER ARCHING OBJECTIVE THIS
PROPOSALS REASONABLE AND A LINE
WITH THE STATE LIBRARY'S CORE
MISSION. OF FOR HISTORICAL
ASSETS. THAT'S IT IS A MORE
FACETED. IT COVERS MANY
DIFFERENT ACTIVE. TO THAT THAT'S
LIBRARY- IT'S ON TRACK AND
MEETING ITS AND MILESTONES.
HANFORD OPEN FOR FUTURE BUDGET
DECISIONS AROUND TO DITCH THE
EFFORTS WE RECOMMEND SOME OF THE
REPORTING OF IN ADDITION TO THE
FUNDING FOR THE AND. ON THE
EIGHT POINT EIGHT CHEN FUND FOR.
THE LIBRARY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. WE THINK
YOU COULD VIEW THIS AS A PILOT
SO CURRENTLY THE STATE LIVE
SPENDING POINT FOR ME DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS- OPERATE A YEAR OF
THE- THIS PURPOSE WOULD FUND TO
GET YEARS FOR TOTAL OF THREE
YEARS TO. SORT OF ASSESS HOW THE
INITIATIVES WERE. OUR CONCERN
HERE IS THE STATE LAW. STILL
COLLECTING INFORMATION ON THE
FIRST IS HAVE BEEN SO ISN'T A
LOT OF INFORMATION AVAIL YET-
THE STATE LIBRARY DOESN'T YET
HAVE A- OF THE NUMBER OF PORTS.
DOESN'T HAVE. IT DEMOCRATS
INFORMATION PARTICIPANT
DEMOGRAPHICS DOESN'T YET HAVE
DATA ON PURCHASE IT ALL COMES.
THE STATE LABOR WHAT ABLE TO
PROVIDE A ROUGH ESTIMATE OF THE
NUMBER OF COURSE HOURS THAT
INCLUDE COMPLETED SO FAR. WHEN
WE CONVERTED THAT TO A ON FG
BASE SIMILAR HOW WE FIND WORK
FOR PROGRAMS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WE HAVE MADE IT IT WAS
A FORTY FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS I
KNOW SUGGEST THE COST OF AROUND
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT. THAT'S A
LOT HIGHER THAN THE RATE THE
STATE PAYS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS. I CAN BECAUSE
INITIATIVES ONGOING IT LIKELY
STILL WILL COLLECT MORE COURSE
HOURS THERE WAS A LIBRARY WILL
CONTINUE TO COLLECT INFORMATION.
ABOUT JUST GIVEN ALL THE
UNCERTAINTIES WITH THIS
INITIATIVE WE- A RIDGE THE
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR. STILL GIVING
THE STATE LAW OPPORTUNE TO. REAP
THE- AND IF THE THEATER DRESS
THE CONCERNS WE RAISE OUR TO
COME BACK TO LEGISLATURE TO
BUDGETS LIKE. FOR FUNDING. ON
THE PROPOSED FIVE MILLION. FUND
FOR LOGICAL. WE'VE THERE ARE TWO
OF. ISSUES CONSIDER. THE FIRST
IS THAT SATE IS CURRENTLY
FUNDING A SCHOOL BASED PROGRAM
TO EXPAND- A SUMMER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES IT'S CALLED
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITY
PRO. THAT PROGRAM COULD ALSO- IN
. UP UP SPROUT SUMMER ME
PURCHASE A- THE- YET THOSE IS A
LITTLE UNCERTAIN. ANALYSTS ISSUE
CONSIDER THAT THIS ARGUMENT. IS
UP OF SOMETHING AMOUNT TO THE
EXIST BASE SUPPORT FOR THE
PROGRAM. AND YET THE IMAGE.
DOESN'T PROPOSED. GUIDANCE WITH
. I'M VIOLATIONS. THE PROGRAM.
SO GIVEN THOSE CONCERNS WE
RECKON TO WATER. FIRST MAKING
THE FUNDS LIMITED TERM RATHER
THAN ONGOING FOR EXAMPLE FOR A
THREE YEAR PERIOD THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE LEDGER TO. REVIEW THE
IMPACT OF THE AUGMENT. AND ALSO
WERE THE OF OTHER AFTER. AND
THEN SECONDLY- THAT THE FUNDING
BE CONNECTED TO OUR STATUTORY
GUIDANCE TO REPORTING LANGUAGE
AND TO THE VALUATION. AND THEN
FINE ON THAT TO PULL TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A RENTAL COSTS WE
DON'T HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
PROPOSAL RECOMMEND YOU DOCTOR.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU- WE
HAVE A REPRESENTED FOR THE STATE
LIBRARY. WELL MISTER LUCAS HERE. LUCAS I THINK YOU'RE A MUTED
SO HE CAN'T HEAR YOU OXTED THE
WAY MRS LUCAS LIKE THAT- WHAT
YOU'RE PLEASURE MISTER TO GO
THROUGH EACH OF THE FOUR ITEMS
THE CHASE JUST WENT THROUGH OR
FOCUS ON THE ONE THAT. PRESENTED
IT'S YOUR CALL YOU KNOW HOW
POWER YOU'D LIKE TO PROCEED YOUR
TIME. WELL MAYBE THE THEY
HEARING- JASON JUST WENT THROUGH
THE FOUR MAIN ITEMS FOR THE
STATE LIBRARY BUT THE FIRST ONE-
INVOLVES. WHAT DIGITIZATION
PROJECTS FOR US WE SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE L. A. O.
TO DO REPORTING- THAT'S BOTH
THEM TO HOW THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IS BEING USED AND
IT'S HELPFUL TO US TO MAKE SURE
WE GET OUR BENCHMARKS- THIS IS
AN PART OF OUR FIVE YEAR PLAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY IS THE- SORT OF PREMIER
RESEARCH LIBRARY THAT THE FIFTH
LARGE ECONOMY AND THE MOST.
GROUP OF PEOPLE EVER BROUGHT TO
GET AS EQUALS IN THE HISTORY OF
HUMAN CIVIL TO SIR THE SECOND
ITEM- REGARDING THE FOUR POINT
MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR FOR
TWO YEARS TO PROVIDE A SERIES OF
JOBS SKILLED TRAINING WORK
DEVELOPMENT- THE- PUT THE REASON
WE PUT IN THE BUDGET REQUEST.
AND AS FOR SAYS SAID US I'M THE
REASON THAT THEY'RE SUPPORTING
ABOUT BUT- IT IS TO HELP CREATE-
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE COMING OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC. SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THE TAP NOW IS IT IS THE
PANDEMIC MORE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
BEEN ENTERING LIBRARIES THROUGH
THEIR DIGITAL DOORS AS OPPOSED
TO THEIR FRONT DOORS. AND ONE OF
THE- TOOLS THAT THAT BUT- COULD
. HAVE BEEN YOU A LIBRARY ARE
THINGS LIKE OKAY SO HOW DO I
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC HOW DO
I MAKE. CAREER SHIFT MANY CAN
SEE ALL THESE SORT OF DIFFERENT
TRENDS THAT ARE OCCURRING
THROUGH. NO SHOES WHAT THEY CALL
A- THE- DARK IT THERE'S SNAPPY
THE GREAT RENTS A- AND- TO THE
L. A. DOES WE ASK FOR THE IT TWO
SO THAT WE COULD GATHER
INFORMATION ON THE BY OF THESE
DIFFERENT SERVICES WHICH IF YOU
LOOK AT THE LIST I MEAN IT'S
THINGS LIKE COURSERA IT'S LINKED
IN LEARNING IT'S- SO IF ANY OF
US IN THE ROOM WANTED TO
SUBSCRIBING PARTICIPATING ANY OF
THOSE IT WOULD BE ABOUT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET A FULL
RIGHT TO GET A FULL MEMBERSHIP
IN EACH OF THOSE THINGS AND IT'S
REALLY. IF YOU TAKE A STEP- IT'S
A VERY COST EFFECTIVE INVESTMENT
TO MAKE THESE SERVICES AVAILABLE
TO. FORTY MILLION CALIFORNIANS
RIGHT OR ANY CALIFORNIANS NEEDS
IT. THROUGH THEIR LOCAL LIBRARY
SYSTEM ON A STATEWIDE BASIS- AS
OPPOSED TO ON AN INDIVIDUAL OR
EVEN ON A LIBRARY JURISDICTIONAL
BASIS. THE THIRD ITEM WAS. AT
THE LIBRARY- I WAS JUST BEFORE
THIS MEETING ON A PHONE CALL
WITH- SENATOR. OFFICE AND WE
SPENT MOST OF THE TIME TALKING
ABOUT- THE FACT THAT SO MANY
KIDS. WHO GET A MEAL DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR SO HUNGRY IN THE
SUMMER. AND IN CALIFORNIA THE
DEPARTMENT OF A- FIGURES ARE
THREE MILLION OUT OF SIX POINT
TWO MILLION PUBLIC SCHOOL KIDS-
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR SUB.
FEDERAL LUNCHEONS. OF THOSE
THREE MILLION KIDS. TEMPERATURES
WE'RE GETTING A MEAL IN THE- IN
THE SUMMER. AND LIBRARIES CAN'T
CAN SOLVE THAT WE'RE NOT TO GET
JENNIFER TO A 100% BY INVOLVING
MORE LIBRARIES. BUT IN THE SHORT
TIME THIS PROGRAM'S BEEN IN
PLACE IT'S INCREASE FROM
SEVENTEEN LIBRARIES
PARTICIPATING APPROX TWO
HUNDRED. THE YEAR BEFORE THE- TO
EVEN DURING PANDEMIC WHEN
PHYSICAL FACILITIES WERE CLOSED
WHY BIRDS THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEALS AND- ADDED TO THE EQUATION
SOMETHING THE OTHER SUMMER MEAL
SITES DON'T. WHICH IS THE IN
RICHMOND AND READING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT LIBRARIES
PROVIDE SO LONG WITH THOSE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS EXCUSE
ME ALONG WITH THOSE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEALS LIBRARIES
PROVIDED A HUNDRED NAY THOUSAND.
THREE BOOKS TO KIDS RIGHT AND
THAT'S BY FAR THE CHEAPEST- WAY
OF CREE MORE OF CREATING
STRONGER READERS IN THE STATE IS
PROVIDING THEM WITH BOOKS AT
HOME. SO ALSO A I MEAN I'M JUST
PASS I MEAN THE LET'S. IN THE
GOT. MEANS OF THE LEGISLATURE
LAST YEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY SINGLE KID WHO'S HUNGRY.
OF CIRCUMSTANCE IS GETS A MEAL
THE SCHOOL YEAR BUT WAS A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION INVEST PLUS
THERE'S ANOTHER HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE NO DOLLAR IN THE- TO
MAKE IMPROVE TO THE- SCHOOL.
CAFETERIA KITCHEN SO. FROM THE
MY- THE TEAM LIKE A FIVE NINE
DOLLAR AND- TO GET STILL TO MAKE
IT EASIER MORE LIBRARIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN FEEDING HUNGRY
KIDS IN THE SUMMER AND- CREATE
THE KIND OF PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ARE GOING TO FEED EVEN MORE
KIDS. BY WORKING WITH LOCAL FOOD
BANKS BY WORKING WITH VOICE
GIRLS CLUBS TO ENSURE THAT THE
MECHANISM IS THERE FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. ALL RIGHT BUT
THE MEAL SERVICE THEY'RE CLOSE
TO THE APPROPRIATE PEOPLE I HAD
LIKE- A SMART AND IN GREATER
SCHEME OF THINGS. MODEST
INVESTMENT. AND IT'S TO THE RENT
BUT- INCREASE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES IS
CHARGED US- IF YOU KNOW THEY I
MEAN THEY'RE A WHOLE OTHER
CONVERTS ABOUT. LIKE WHY AND WHY
IS IT THAT MUCH BUT I MEAN IT'S
VERY HELPFUL TO THE STATE
LIBRARY HAVE MONEY IN THE BUDGET
TO MAKE UP THIS TWO MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE IN OUR UP. THANK
END OF REAP. OKAY THANK YOU WELL
WITH A LEVEL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
HAPPENING THROUGHOUT OUR
LIBRARIES THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS AND- WE APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK AND BEING INNOVATIVE
AND NOT JUST. HAVING THE OLD
LIBRARY SYSTEM WE HAD FIFTY
YEARS AGO. THANK YOU NEED TO BE
INVOLVED IN ADAPT SO- I DON'T
HAVE ANY BACKLASH ON THESE
PROPOSALS. THINGS- NINE FROM FOR
MARKETING WILL HOLD THESE ISSUES
OPEN UNTIL AFTER THE ME WITH ME
REVI. WE'LL NOW PROCEED PUBLIC.
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
HAVE A FEW PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
PLEASE LINE AT AND YOU'D LIKE TO
PER. ON THE- ON THE- PHONE THE
PUBLIC TOLD NUMBER WE WANT SEX
HE COULD PLEASE- KNOWS THAT THE
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN
EIGHT SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN THE CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIFTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN- ONE
MINUTE OR LESS PLEASE- PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU YES SIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
TONY RICE REPRESENTING YOUR
NIGHT AWAY WHICH IS AN
EDUCATIONAL POLICY THINK TANK.
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THAT AT SCHOOL WELL WITH SIX THE
WORK- COPPER. WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AS WELL- THERE MARCH
IS CRADLE TO CAREER AND
EVERYTHING IN THE AND THEY FULLY
. ISSUE ONE WHAT'S THE SOCKETS
IN THE DO AND UNDER YOUR MR
CHAIRED SOME OF YOUR COLLEAGUE.
TO REDUCE THE BARRIERS
ASSOCIATED THE CAL GRANT
PROPOSAL WE THINK THAT WOULD GO
A LONG WAYS TOWARDS- CONTINUING
TO DEVELOP THE WORKFORCE INCOME
- UPON BUSINESSES A WE CAN TO
COME OUT OF OUT OF THE PAIR. OF
ANY FINE MISS CHAIR I HAVE A
SEPARATE CLASS I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO MR LUCAS'S- ISSUE ON
THE STATE LIBRARY AS WELL AS
THAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE THANK
YOU. I'VE KNOWN GREG FOR TWENTY
YEARS I I'M A BIG FAN OF HIS
HE'S KNOWS THIS BUT FROM THE
CITY OF WHITTIER PERSPECTIVE WE
HAVE A ROBUST WELL RECEIVED-
LIBRARY SYSTEM IN WHICH THEY ARE
IN IT'S A REMARKABLE- HOW MANY-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY FULLY
SUPPORT THAT- WE FOUND WE HAVE
AN ACCEPTED. LIBRARIAN DOWN
THERE WHO WORKS REALLY CLOSELY
WITH GREG AND HIS. WE'VE BEEN
EXCEPTIONALLY- BENEFICIAL OF HIS
LEADERSHIP AND WEEKS BEFORE
SUPPORT ALL OF HIS- INTERESTS AS
WELL SO. THANK YOU FOR MUCH. GET
MORE EVERYONE MY NAME'S PRASAD
I'M THE BY PRESIDENT AFFAIRS FOR
THE STUDENT SENATE FLIP
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND WEBER TO
BE CO SPONSORS OF AB SEVENTY
FORTY SIX WITH FEELS CAL GRANT
REFORM AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO MAKE SURE THAT THE
THREE HIGHER EDUCATIONAL
SEGMENTS ARE MORE ACCESSIBLE
EQUITABLE FOR STUDENTS I AM
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY STUDENTS
THAT DO QUALIFY FOR COVERAGE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY RECEIVE IT AND IT
CAN HELP TREMENDOUSLY PAYING FOR
THAT NEED THIS. AND NOT JUST
TUITION BECAUSE AS WE KNOW
TUITION IS NOT THE FULL COST OF
COLLEGE SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ALLOW MORE FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS SO THEY CAN HAVE A AND
GO BACK INTO THE WORK FORCE.
THANK YOU. THEY GIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHOW MCCARTY MY NAME
IS TAREQ AZIZ I'M A STUDENT
DAVIS AND THE VICE CHAIR OF
REALLY IN TRANSITION AFFAIRS
OFFICER FOR THE SOONEST SEES AND
I'M ALSO WITH THE FINANCIAL
COALITION WE ASK YOU TODAY JUST
RUNS TALK TO HIM THANK WE ASK
YOU TO DO TODAY STRONG TO MAKE
ONGOING IN OUR FINAL A AND TO
SUPPORT CAL GRANT. EFFORTS BEING
UNDERTAKEN THROUGH THE BUDGET-
AND AS OUTLINED BY THE SENATE
COMMISSION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MY NAME MICHELLE ANDREWS I
A THIRD YEAR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT I YOU. DAVIS I ALSO HERE
THE UC STUDENTS. AND THE FIXED.
AID COALITION- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE CALGARY MODERNIZATION. I
AM ONE OF LIKE JOHN. ONE OF THE
TO. SEVENTY TWO. STUDENTS WHO
DOES NOT CURRENTLY GET CAL GRANT
- EVEN AFTER MY MOTHER LAW HER
JOB DURING THE PANDEMIC I STILL
DO NOT QUALIFY FOR CAL GRANT- ON
AND THAT HAS LED TO MY FAMILY
HAVING TO TAKE OUT. TENS OF THE
- OF LOANS TO FUND MY- COUPLE OF
YEARS OF COLLEGE. ON AND I'VE
WHO STUDYING HUMAN I DAVIS- I
KNOW THAT EDUCATION IS A HUMAN
RIGHT. AND A LOT OF STUDENTS IN
OUR STATE ARE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS UNACCEPTABLE-
SO I URGE YOU TO. NOT ONLY
SUPPORT ON AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX AND CAL GRANDMOTHER TO SAY.
EFFORTS TO FULLY FUND THE CAL
GRANT SO THAT IT CAN REACH FULL
POTENTIAL TO HELP OUR STATE'S
HIGHER. SYSTEM THANK YOU. GOOD
TERM ACCORDING. RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF. TRUST WEST FIRST WE
STAND IN SUPPORT WITH FINANCIAL
AID COALITION AND THE STUDENT
CENTER PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
COVER. WHEN FREE. AS A- IN ITEM
ONE TO EXPAND. A SYSTEM. IN WAY
. WILL UP WITH FIRST. FOR THE
ALLOCATIONS FOR C. SAR. AND THE
CASH FOR COLLEGE- V. I. NUMBER
THREE AND ASK THAT YOU ALSO
CONSIDER THE FACT REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WITH CHAMBER MM MY
NAY IS MOLLY THE ACTUAL I'M LIKE
ARE UC'S THE AND I'VE HEARD YOU
ARE YET TO THIS YOU SEE A IN OUR
HISTORY HAS THIS. I AM HERE
TODAY I PART OF THE FEES FOR A
RELEASE TO THINK YOU FOR YOUR TO
FOR OURS AND YOUR KAMALA TO RULE
REAL AND MEANINGFUL CAN GRAHAM A
C. AFTER I ONE OF THE OF THREE
FOX THE STATE THAT DOESN'T- FACT
THIS DRUG SO I FOR CALL. BECAUSE
WHEN I AID DOESN'T COVER THE
COST OF A I HAVE TO WORK ALL
WORKS OF OUR YOU KNOW TO
ACCOMMODATE MY TUITION FISH AND
ACTUALLY ME MAKE THIS NEEDS SO
ASK YOU TAKE TO TAKE EXTRA STEPS
IN MAKING ONGOING IN FINANCE AID
AND SUPPORT THE PROGRAM THINGS
THEY OF A FIRST ANOTHER THROUGH
THE BUDGET AND I'LL LIKE BY
BECOMING TO MANY COMING. CENTER
EXPLAIN AID AND- WE WANT LONG
FOR WE LESSEN THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU NOW FOR. TO OUR CALLER
. ARE TELEPHONE. I TO WE HAVE A
HAVE ANY ONLINE. WE DO ABOUT
PUBLIC FROM NUMBER. PLEASE AHEAD. I REMEMBER SIGNING IS MEGAN
THERE AND APOSS I'M LOOKING AT
YOU KEEP ALEXANDER ACTIVE YOU
KNOW I'M LATE I MEAN THAT PART
OF THE PLAYED COALITION THANK
YOU OR YOUR FOR- I NINETY
STUDENTS WALKED OUT OF THING
INTERNET AID BECAUSE OF THE OUT
COPPER INSISTS AND THAT MEANT
AND FOUGHT HARD TO GET AND IF
YOU CAN SECURE FOR ME HAD TO
WORK WELCOME TO MY TIME AND- IN
THE YEARS. AND THAT HAD NEVER
BECOME IN EXAGGERATED THAT- AND
I HAVE TO HAVE A LONG THIS
REPORT- SO OVERALL WE AFTER
TODAY TO TAKE THE TIME STANCE
AND AGAIN ON GO ABOUT THE AND
ARE GONNA AID AND CAL GRANT ON A
BASE THREE EIGHTY FIVE FOR YOU
AND OUTLINED BY THE- EIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TITLED IT OUTWARD.
HOWEVER FAR TOO MANY CALIPARI
ARE MADE UNABLE TO AFTER THE
HIGHER EDUCATION DUE TO A CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT FROM BEING.
OVERLY COMPLEX OUR STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES ADVOCATE. COOLEY
URSULA AND THE GOVERNOR TO
PRIORITIZE NEW ONGOING RESOURCES
TO IMPLEMENT THE CONTRACT TO BE
FRAMEWORK AT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
THE POLICE UP BY THE CONTRACT
PROCESSING GREATLY EXPANDED TO
STUDENTS TO GET THE BUS. NOW
WITH THE TIME TO ACT SIMPLY PUT
THIS IS A RACIAL EQUITY ISSUE.
ON THE CAL GRANT REMOVING
RATIONING MECHANISM FOR CABLE
PROVIDED CAPTIVATED A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL AID THE
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE BLACK AND
BLACK MAC. THIS YEAR WITH THE
CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO KEEP THE COLLEGE STREAM
AFFORDABLE FOR GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS TO COP AND ACCEPT
THE BARTON NATIONWIDE PROVIDING
AFFECTED. STUDENT CENTER AND
CAPITAL FINANCIAL EXPERT FROM
SHOULD LOOK. LIKE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE. AND
QUESTION COMES FROM A LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR IN NUMBERS MY NAME
IS RITA MEDINA I LOOK DIRECTOR
OF STATE POLICY AND ADVOCACY
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHT SURE NOT. TO GIVE BACK THE
PROPOSED ADJUSTMENT TO THE
PAYMENT SERVICE. GRANT ST- AT
LEAST A POINT THAT WE SUPPORT
THE STATE SENATE KICKING DOLLARS
AN HOUR MAKING. ADJUSTMENTS THE
PART TIME STUDENT AT THE WILL
HELP MAKE THE PROGRAM MORE
ATTRACTIVE FOR STUDENTS AT THE
THIRTY. THANKS MUCH TO SUPPORT
THAT REGARDING DURING. I AGREE
WITH THE L. A. OVER. TO REJECT
MOVING THE DECENT DOG IN. DURING
BLANCA. WELL THE INSTITUTION MAY
NOT BE FEEL AND- URGENT NEED FOR
THIS DREAM FINE WE BELIEVE THERE
ARE MANY FOR THAT. OPEN AT WE
SUPPORT DAHLE FRIEND DOCUMENTED
STUDENTS INTO PROGRAMS THAT THAT
. I THANK. ACCIDENT ARE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR DACA FOR FIRST TIME
AND IT WORK. OTHER SOURCES OF
FINANCE SUPPORT WILL BECOME EVEN
CRITICAL AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT
. IS STRONG AND AVAIL. BUT IT'S
ACROSS CAMPUS. WE HOPE THAT AS
THE PROGRAM COULD. WE WILL BE TO
GATHER THINKING DATA BY YOU
CAN'T TO TALK ABOUT WHO IS THE-
BAR WHERE WHERE THEY GOING TO.
AND WHAT ARE THEIR NAMES ACROSS
THE FIFTY. AND FINANCIAL IF YOU
AND PROMOTE OF THE PROGRAM X.
ACROSS. THEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND I QUESTION OR NOT
COMMENT COMES LINE OF SEVEN THIS
AT. A GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY- I'M
NOT IDEA I'M NOT YOU SEE BURKE
AND I OF GENERAL UP DID NOT A
ACT YOUR- AND I IN YOUR CONSIDER
OF THE BY FOR- CAL TO MAKE
MISSION I THE PRIOR TO FUNDING.
FOR THE CAL EQUITY FRAMEWORK. IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT WOULD
POTENTIAL LEADER ABLE SIXTY IT
IMPERATIVE THAT NOT ONLY BE FOR
GREATER POTENTIAL THAT THE TO
CALL. BUT ALSO MAKES THAT
STUDENTS ARE IN ADEQUATE WITH
ANY OTHER STUDENTS IN ORDER TO
FIX. AFTER GOING TO. I NOT
PUSHEDIT DIDN'T LIKE THAT ARE
IMPORTANT IN ORDER MAKE SURE
THAT RECIPIENT NEED NOT HAVE THE
ON BEYOND UNDER ANY ARE BURGERS. IT CAN THEIR NEEDS ARE AND
ADDITIONALLY IT I'M OUT OF THAT
. THE RECIPIENT BENJAMIN PRO
LEGIBLE. POPPING MINIMAL IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE MONEY BY. THAT
BUT I MEAN OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT
CAN. BLOCKED THEM PREPARED FIRST
THAT AND I THOUGHT- PROPOSAL THE
PROPOSAL. THAT AND MORE- AND
WHAT THE GONNA- THAT YOU SUPPORT
PEOPLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
SPEAKER. COMMENT FROM NUMBER TWO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN KERR IN MEMBER
MINOR IS CHARU FORTY AND I'M A
STUDENT AT CINEMA STATE YOU
KNOW. AS WELL AS THE DIRECT
PLEDGES AFFAIRS AND OUTREACH THE
SAID TO. INC HERE ON K. I'M HERE
TODAY AS A PART OF THE FIX
FINANCIALLY COALITION TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
OF OUR STUDENTS AND YOUR
COMMITMENT TO A ROBUST AND
MEANINGFUL CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION AFTER. FOR MOST
STUDENTS EDUCATION IS OUR TICKET
INTO A CAREER WE NEED FINANCIAL
RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
OUR GOALS ACHIEVABLE AND SO THAT
WE CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE AND
ECONOMY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CAN EXPECT YOUR PLACE. CONNECT
COMMENT COMES FROM MY NUMBER
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR MANAGER RECORDING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAMANTHA SAYING WHAT'S
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
THE HISTORICAL INVESTMENTS IN
STATE FINANCIAL AID TO REACH
MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON IF
YOU WANT OF YOUR AGENDA TODAY WE
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD ON THIS MOVEMENT
TOWARDS EQUITY IN OUR FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM BY ADOPTING THE
CALGARY EQUITY FRAMEWORK WOULD
YOU ASK OUR SUPPORT ALONGSIDE
COMMENTS ALREADY MADE BY THE FIX
FINANCIAL AID COALITION. JUST
WANTED TO ADD- TO QUICKLY GIVEN
OUR WORK AS PART OF THE CAMPAIGN
FOR CALIFORNIA BORROWERS RIGHT
THE STATE IN RECENT YEARS HAVE
MADE GREAT STRIDES TO REIN IN
THE PREDATORY STUDENT LOAN
SERVICING INDUSTRY BUT ON THE
FRONT END OF THE COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY SPECTRUM. INSERTED
MANY STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID WILL HELP WITH
FIGHTING THE STATE STUDENT DEBT
CRISIS YOU KNOW THE COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
LOANS AND SIMILARLY THE CAL
RIGHT EQUITY FRAMEWORK WILL
SUPPORT MORE THE STUDENTS AND
LOW INCOME FAMILIES ATTAIN
HIGHER EDUCATION WITHOUT
CRIPPLING STUDENT DEBT. THANK
YOU AND- SUPPORT THE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK. IN THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS
PLEASE. OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM LINE NUMBER NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THERE MY NAME IS
GENEVIEVE AND I AM A STUDENT AT
MEETINGS. AND ALSO A
REPRESENTATIVE OF GENERATION.
I'M CALLING TWO DAYS AFTER THE
PRIORITIZE. THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK AS YOU LOOK AT THE KEY
FACTOR- BUDGET PROPOSAL. IN MY
HERE AT UCSB OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS I AM SURROUNDED BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE BEING BURDENED WITH
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE HAD FEW- PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ADDITIONAL CAREGIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES. BLACK TO WORK.
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND O YOU
RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY AND PAY
FOR COLLEGE ON TOP OF THESE
THINGS ARE AN UNFAIR BURDEN
THAT'S GETTING IN THE WAY HE
SAID. MONTEREY POP ALSO DO NEED
TO BE PART OF THE CAL GRANT
FRAMEWORK AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE HOPING THAT YOU WILL
ATTRACT BY PROCEEDING WITH THE.
PLAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX BUT- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M CHRISTINE
AT THE CAR- REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LIBRARY ASSOCIATION
REGARDING TO STATE LIBRARY ITEMS
WE THANK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
FIRST PARTNER FOR THEIR SUPPORT
OF THE PROGRAM KNOWN AS LUNCH AT
THE LIBRARY AND FOR THE PROPOSED
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET BEFORE YOU. LUNCH AT THE
LIBRARY IS IN DESPERATE NEED OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
LIBRARIES MAY EXTEND THE PROGRAM
TO THOUSANDS MORE FOOD INSECURE
CHILDREN AND TEENS DURING THE
SUMMER MONTHS. EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO RUN A
STATEWIDE SUMMER LUNCH PROGRAM
IS SIMPLY NOT SUSTAINABLE AND
THE NEED IS ONLY GROWING. THE
LIBRARY IS A SAFE NON JUDGMENTAL
SPACE WHERE KIDS CAN COME AND
GET A MEAL AND USE THE QUALITY
PROGRAMMING AT THE LIBRARY. SOME
PARENTS TELL OUR LIBRARY
DIRECTORS BUT IT'S THE ONLY MEAL
PER CHILD MAY HAVE ALL DAY WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE ITEM
ENTITLED ONLINE JOB TRAINING AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. NEVER
WERE THESE UPSKILLING PROGRAMS
SO IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIANS
AND PEOPLE GO BACK TO WORK OR
LEARN A NEW SKILL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE NUMBER THIRTY
ONE PLEASE CALL AT. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M NOT
ABOUT THE WITH THE CALIFORNIA X.
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE CAL GRANT REFORM PROPOSAL
THAT SEEKS TO REMOVE ELIGIBILITY
BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS AND ADULT
LEARNERS ALTHOUGH VERY GRATEFUL
FOR LAST YEAR'S INVESTMENT THAT
GPA VERIFICATION ISSUE CONTINUES
TO BE A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER. FOR
ADULT LEARNERS ATTENDING OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE OUR STATE
LEADERS JOIN BASKETBALL CAL
GOVERNMENT FORM THIS YEAR THAT
WILL ENABLE STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
THEIR EDUCATION. AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BAKER PLEASE. NEXT COMMENT OF
SHORELINE NUMBER THIRTY PLEASE
BUT- HELLO MY NAME IS ALEX NILES
I SERVED AS THE CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
HOUSTON SENATORS NATION I'M ALSO
SEND YOU SEE SANTA BARBARA- I
LIKE THE COLD TODAY EXPRESSED
SUPPORT THE- H. ORDER TO. BE I
DON'T WANT TO. ON. LEAVING WORK
. AND AID COURT STREET GROUPS.
ESPECIALLY BROWN DR STUDENTS ARE
. WE HAVE EVERYWHERE YOU'RE USED
STUDENTS- PART RECIPIENTS-
BECOMES ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THERE TO BE- WORK AVAILABLE FOR
NOT DOCUMENTED- THE COUPLE
DIDN'T. ONE POSSIBILITY IS
FUNDING GOTTEN SUPER THAT YOU
CAN'T TURN THAT PROVIDE PAID.
THAT'S THE WORKING TO- THE BAY
ON DOT DOT DOT STUDENTS. HAVING
DOING JOBS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. S. COMES FROM A
LINE OF THIRTY TWO PLEASE. THIS
IS GOOD MORNING MCCARTY
LAMBORGHINI PRODUCT I DON'T EVEN
THINK I DON'T ON INTERNAL. HM
OUT THE- I'M HERE TODAY I
DEPARTMENTS INCLUSION THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU CAN. YEAH BASICALLY THE
WAY WE SUPPORTING STUDENTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT MAKE COULDN'T
GET. BUT NO SINGLE. AND STUDENTS
WORKING PROFESSIONALS BACK TO.
THEIR MEANS AND I THINK SHE'S.
MICHAEL BUBLE ONE ADDITIONAL TO.
AND BY ENSURING BY I THINK
YOU'RE HAVE WHICH- TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE INTO THRIVE IN OUR- AND
TOOK BOTHER THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA. ANGEL TO COMPLETE TO
SUPPORT THE TROUBLE PARK WHICH-
AND BACK BY COMMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW BAKER. BY TWENTY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR MARKET
FUTURE REP THE LAW ANGELES
COUNTY OF SUPERVISORS AND OF
PICK UP PURPLE TO PRINT EIGHT
EIGHT NINE DOLLARS FOR LIBRARY
BASE ON MY TRAINING AS A
PROGRAMMES AND I THOUGHT CHAIR
TOPICAL BY THE FUTURE HERE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK SPEAKER
PLEASE. BY. ELEVEN GOOD MORNING
CAROLINA MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS ON OTHER TRYING TO VICE
PRESIDENT LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIPHATE INSTITUTION
I'M HERE STATE FARM SIX
FINANCIAL AID COALITION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR
STUDENTS AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
A ROBUST AND MEANINGFUL CAL
GRANT MODERNIZATION COOPER. ARE
CURRENTLY TEND TO THOUSANDS
STUDENTS WERE ACROSS THE STATE
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO COLLEGE.
AND MEETING BASICALLY BECAUSE
ARE KERN FINANCIAL. AND HOW IT
DOESN'T ADEQUATELY. THE COST OF. TEN THE SERGEANTS BEING.
HUNGRY AND WEARING BY THE MENTAL
. I AND THERE STATE RATHER THAN
THEIR EDUCATION. HOW ARE THEY
STILL TOGETHER ABOUT DUCATION
WITHOUT ACCESS TO BASICALLY.
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA DESERVE
BETTER MORE JEFF PLAIN SILLY
THIS. WITH MINI ONE THAT
TRANSLATE HOURS CAN CONTINUE
FEEL ARE REQUIRED WORKERS AND
OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY FOR KOBE
NINE. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. LIVE FOUR. THE MORNING
CARE MCCARTY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TRENT MURPHY
NON STUDENT AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY STANISLAUS AND THE
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS
COORDINATOR FOR ITS ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS I'M HERE TODAY IS A
PART OF THE FIX FINANCIAL A
COALITION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. I'M ONE OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS THAT ARE LEFT OUT OF
RECEIVING FINANCIAL AID BECAUSE
OF CAL GRANT OUTDATED SYSTEM
RENDON BASIC COST OF LIVING
EXPENSES CONTINUE TO INCREASE
DRASTICALLY WHILE WAGES HAVE
REMAINED STAGNANT WITH INFLATION
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT WAGES ARE
ACTUALLY DECLINING IN PURCHASING
POWER FOR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. I MYSELF AM AN ON
CAMPUS STUDENT WORKER WHICH
MEANS I WEEKLY HOURS ARE CAPPED
TO A MAXIMUM OF TWENTY I AM
THOUSANDS OF OTHER STUDENTS WERE
ON CAMPUS WORKERS SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD TO MEET OUR BASIC NEEDS
WHILE BEING A STUDENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AT THE CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES RUNNING PUNCH
FINANCIAL AID ARE NOT RECTIFIED.
THAT IS WHY I URGE ALL
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS TO SUPPORT
THE CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK
AND AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS
WILL BECOME. THE NEXT GENERATION
OF CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE. THANK
YOU NICK BAKER PLAY. THE. THIRTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING GEMMA PARTY
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS GABE FINER
I'M DUE TO UTILIZE I'M HERE
TODAY IT'S HARD TO BE FIXED BY
AID COALITION IS WELL THE THING
YOU FOR COULD THE- OF THE CAL
MUNGER EFFORT I'M SURE AT THE ON
THINK YOUR BUDGET AFTER WE KNOW
HOW HAVE OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MORE STILL WHO ACT WITH
THE COW GRANT. BUT THE OF THE
YET AND FINANCIALLY TO BILL OVER
THE CALL AND DIFFICULT AND NOT
WHICH ONLY DISCOURAGES THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS FROM APPLYING
RECEIVING THAT BUT ALSO FROM OUR
HOW TO BEST LEVERAGE THE
RESOURCES THEY'RE GIVEN FOR
NEEDS FROM THE STATE UNDER FROM
THE CROP. OVER THIRTY EDUCATION
NOT BE GROUPS. UP RELEASED A
LETTER ON THE URGENT THE NEED
FOR PASSAGE EIGHT AB SEVENTY
FORTY THIRD. THIS IS NOT ONE OF
OUR- TO ABOUT IT THE EVEN MORE
AT CANADA TO THE- THE LAST.
THANK THANK NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
THIRTY THIRTY. ANTIPHON THE
ANSWER FOR I AND WE ARE THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE COULD FOR
THAT GRANT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN EIGHT SEVENTY FORTY
WHICH TOGETHER WITH ON THE ON
COMMITMENT TO MAKE MORE ABILITY
A REAL FOR ALL CAL. IT SEVENTEEN
FORTY SO. BY THE KU GRANT
PROGRAMS TO EARLIER IN CLEARING
. TO AND FAMILIES ABOUT HOW MUCH
THEY CAN EPECT TO RECEIVE A
GRANT AID. REMOVAL VERY SUCH NOT
. LOW INCOME FROM ACCESSING AID
AND HELP WITH THE RAPIDLY NON
TUITION COLLEGE COSTS. RECOVER
NINETEEN COMPUTER SIX A BIG TEAM
AND IT'S GAP. VITAL CENTER THAT
INTEREST TWENTY PROGRAM IT'S
MORE NEEDED AT. THANK YOU
CLEARLY AND COMMITMENT TO AND
OUR COLLEGE BACK BY EQUITY AND.
SIX THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER
PLEASE. ONE THIRTY SIX. THE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MONEYBOX WHICH CAN
TURN OUT UCLA AND A NUMBER OF
CHEN I'M A STUDENT BUT EDUCATION
ACT ORGANIZATION AND I'M CALLING
TO ASK PRIORITIZE. PROGRESS
RIGHT COSTA COLLEGE THOUGHT AND
THEN HIGH IN THE SPRING AND
PARTY I'M LOOKING WOULD BE
BACKED BY THE EQUITY FRAMEWORK
AND PRIOR TO THIS THE BACK UP.
AND ALLOW TO PROCEED TEACHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. TEN THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO
GOOD MORNING JEREMY MY NAME
BLOWN UP OF THE STUDENT
COMMISSIONER THE CAL YOU CAN A
COMMITTEE. MEMBER- ON THE
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE COLLEGE FIFTY
I'M HERE AT OF THE BIG AID
COOLEY THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND
TO THE CALIFORNIA'S. ATTENDANCE
DOCUMENTS AND THAT THE EIGHTY
FIVE THREE AND SO RELYING ON HOW
TO ALLOW ME TO IT CALLED IT
URGED THAT WE TOOK YOU CAN
FUTURE HEALTH BY CONTINUING
INVEST IN. INSPECTING FINANCIAL
AID THANK YOU. THANK NEXT BIG
PLEASE. I AM VERY NINE- HELLO
CHAIR AND AT THE NEW- MY NAME'S
I'M STUDENT AT MCKENNA COLLEGE
IN A MEMBER GENERATION UP. TO
DATE- URGE YOU TO FUNDING THE
GRANT PRIMER- I WAS GOING-
COLLEGE UP PROCESS BY FAR THE
MOST INTIMIDATING AT THE AT WHAT
- NOW WITH WHAT THAT MY COULD
TAKE IT TO HELP ME NOW IT BUT
THAT NOT THE CASE FOR MANY OF MY
FRIENDS CLASSMATES AND IT BE THE
STUDENT LEARNING THEIR OPT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T REALIZE
THEY'RE FOR CERTAIN OF EIGHT
LIKE THE CALGARY- LUCKILY THE
COVER IN EQUITY FREE AT THIS.
COMMON THANK TIME AND I'M GOING
GRATEFUL FOR THAT THE IN THE
LEGISLATURE LAW YEAR- AND I HOPE
THAT THIS YEAR WILL BE CONTAINED
OF THAT ATTEND TO STUDENT NEED
IN THE FALL OF TWENTY PUBLIC
COULD FRAMEWORK THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT. PLEASE BY THE- THANK YOU
ACROSS AND SENDING MY NAME IS
GOOD THAT I'M THAT BUT RECORD
OKAY IS A GUY OF THE ASSOCIATION
AND UNDER THE- MEMBER OF
ASSOCIATE INCORPORATED CAL POLY
LUIS OF- AT OF THE PLAN G.
CONDITION AND AT ONE TO SUPPORT
IT NEEDS OF FORTY. OUR DIRECTLY
YOU KNOW WHAT IT BE A MEMBERS
MCCARTY JUDGE EMMA BACK IN THE
BUT HE NEVER EIGHT BEFORE FORTY
THREE AND THAT ONE TWO I HOPE
THAT AB SEVENTY FOUR SIX BUT
THAT IT IS WHAT STEP IN TACKLING
MARC AND I BEFORE I WAS
RECOMMENDED THE GOVERNOR HAS
PERCENT PROJECTED. IN MANY
CORPORATE UTILITY AND CAL GRANT
UPON WITH IMPORTANT STEP IN
ATTIC AND BY BY AHEAD BY TO MORE
ABOUT OUR FUTURE- AND LESS ABOUT
TAKING BECAUSE I PERSONALLY
ACTUALLY COME UP WITH QUICK
HAVEN'T NEEDED THAT AND WHAT.
I'LL TAKE ALL THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND WE WILL AYE
REGROUP ON THESE ISSUES AND THE
COMING MONTHS AND WEEKS THANK
YOU SO MUCH MAJOR.